Hello, and welcome to your second drink of Dream Team.
We have some really great behind-the-scenes tidbits about this episode,
straight from Brian Baumgartner.
Oh, yeah.
I mean, that storyline with Kevin being at front reception is so good.
I was curious if the scene had any extra moments that didn't make it in the original broadcast,
and I found this funny talking head.
It's in the shooting draft that Kevin would have said.
你好，欢迎收听第二杯《办公室》播客。关于这一集，我们从布莱恩·鲍姆加特纳那里得到了一些非常棒的幕后花絮。哦，是的。我是说，凯文在前台接电话的那条故事线太精彩了。我很好奇这一幕是否有没在原版播出中出现的额外片段，结果我找到了这个有趣的采访镜头。在拍摄剧本中，凯文原本会说出这段话。
So I'm going to set it up, okay?
Kevin is answering the phones, and it is not going to.
well, right?
Yeah, because Pam is off starting her new company with Michael.
They need someone to sit at reception.
That's right.
Pam has left.
And Jim has this talking head.
所以我来铺垫一下，好吗？凯文在接电话，但情况不太妙，对吧？是的，因为帕姆和迈克尔一起去创业了。他们需要有人坐在前台。没错。帕姆离开了。然后吉姆有这样一个采访镜头。
You know, it made it into the episode where Jim says, Charles is having Kevin cover the phones
for a while.
How do I say this diplomatically?
I think Kevin is doing exactly as well as anyone might have expected someone like him
to perform in a position like that.
And then more phones ring and action happens.
but in the shooting draft, Kevin would have had a talking head immediately after that,
and he would have said, I'm giving myself a B.
你知道，剧集里保留了吉姆说的那句：查尔斯让凯文暂时负责接电话。我该怎么委婉地说呢？我觉得凯文的表现正如大家对像他这样的人在那个职位上的预期一样。然后电话又响了，动作戏开始了。但在拍摄剧本中，凯文在那之后紧接着有一个采访镜头，他本来说的是：我给自己打个B。
A B.
He thinks he's doing okay.
Also in the shooting draft, Kevin would have answered the phone, and he would have said,
Dunder Kevin, this is Kevin.
Amazing.
I wonder, because what made it in the episode is Brian is Kevin saying Dunder Mifflin,
this is Kevin.
And I wonder if Brian just said it properly.
一个B。他觉得他做得还不错。同样在拍摄剧本中，凯文接电话时本来说的是：邓德·凯文，我是凯文。太棒了。我很好奇，因为剧集里播出的是布莱恩饰演的凯文说：邓德·米夫林，我是凯文。我怀疑布莱恩是不是只是把它说对了。
Oh, he forgot to mention.
mess it up. Yes. Maybe so. Because the shooting draft said, Dunder Kevin. This is Kevin.
Well, lady, you and I saw a lot of background catches when we were breaking down this episode,
but I've got another one for you. This one comes in from Rinell in Brooklyn, New York, who says,
Ladies, I know you love a background catch. And at one minute and 56 seconds, when Pam is saying
that today is her first day at her new job at Michael Scott Paper Company, and then she points to a sign in the lawn,
I thought at first Michael had put his own sign over a real estate sign, but I think it's a sign for someone running for office. Did you notice that?
I did not catch that. I didn't catch that. So I went to the script to see how it was described. And Rinell, you are correct. In the shooting draft, it says exterior Michael's condo morning, a sunny day. Pam is dressed in a new skirt suit. She's posing like a spokesmodel.
哦，他忘了提。搞砸了。是的。也许是这样。因为拍摄剧本上写的是：邓德·凯文，我是凯文。好吧，女士，我们在拆解这一集时发现了很多背景细节，但我还有一个要告诉你。这是来自纽约布鲁克林的里内尔发来的，她说：女士们，我知道你们喜欢背景细节。在1分56秒时，当帕姆说今天是她在迈克尔·斯科特造纸公司新工作的第一天，然后她指向草坪上的一个牌子时，我起初以为迈克尔把自己的牌子盖在了一个房地产招牌上，但我认为那是一个竞选公职的牌子。你注意到了吗？我没注意到。我没注意到。所以我去查了剧本，看看它是怎么描述的。里内尔，你是对的。在拍摄剧本中写道：外景，迈克尔的公寓，早晨，阳光明媚。帕姆穿着一套新的裙装。她像个代言模特一样摆姿势。
for the camera's amusement by a sign stuck into Michael's front lawn that reads Michael Scott Paper Company
Incorporated. If we look closely, we can see for Congress peeking out under the new sign.
So yes, they just slapped their new company, like name on someone else's sign.
I know. It's like someone had a like running for Congress. Yes. I thought that was so great.
I love that detail. And also, I love that they described.
Pam's outfit as a new skirt suit. Yes. Well, you know, the network, it had to be a skirt.
I know. We talk about it. Mm-hmm. You know, I was actually curious if there were any candy bag
alts for Pam's talking head about her starting her new job. Oh, yeah, there were. Many.
为了摄像机的娱乐，站在插在迈克尔前草坪上的一个牌子旁，上面写着迈克尔·斯科特造纸公司。如果我们仔细看，可以看到新牌子下面露出了“竞选国会议员”的字样。所以是的，他们只是把他们新公司的名字贴在了别人的牌子上。我知道。就像有人在竞选国会议员一样。是的。我觉得这太棒了。我喜欢这个细节。而且，我也喜欢他们把帕姆的装束描述为一套新的裙装。是的。嗯，你知道，电视网，那必须是一条裙子。我知道。我们谈过这个。嗯。你知道，我其实很好奇帕姆关于她开始新工作的采访镜头是否有其他的备选方案。哦，是的，有。很多。
Many. I can tell you there were. Well, I found two treasures that might give you all an idea of Pam's
life at front reception. Jenna, you're probably going to remember these. Here, actually, why don't you read them?
Oh, sure. Yes. Okay. Here's one. This isn't crazy. People start companies all the time. And who better to start a paper company with than the best paper salesman Scranton has ever seen? Besides, I needed a change in scenery. Answering phones and faxing in Creed's prescriptions was wearing on me.
What are Creed's prescriptions? I don't know, but I guess there were a lot. Okay, this next one really got me.
Okay. I have a ton of faith in Michael.
But it's not just about that.
I needed a change.
There's only so many times you can debate with Kevin about pizza pockets versus pizza before you reach witsend.
很多。我可以告诉你确实有很多。好吧，我找到了两个宝藏，可能会让你们对帕姆在前台的生活有个概念。珍娜，你可能会记得这些。来，其实，你为什么不读一下呢？哦，当然。好的。这是其中一个。这并不疯狂。人们一直在创业。还有谁比斯克兰顿有史以来最好的纸张推销员更适合一起创办造纸公司呢？再说，我需要换个环境。接电话和帮克里德传真处方让我感到疲惫。克里德的处方是什么？我不知道，但我猜有很多。好吧，下一个真的让我笑了。好的。我对迈克尔有十足的信心。但这不仅仅是关于那个。我需要改变。在达到忍无可忍之前，你和凯文争论披萨口袋和披萨的区别的次数是有限的。
I do feel like, you know, at reception, you got stuck.
If someone came up there, right?
And Kevin in the early seasons would go up to Pam and like lean on reception and talk.
Oh, my gosh, talker, you're off.
Well, we had another fun background catch from Victoria S from Langley, British Columbia.
who said at eight minutes and five seconds, I noticed that Pam or Michael doesn't lock the door when
they leave Michael's condo. Why does this happen all the time in movies or was it intentional?
Well, you know, I was rewatching this and they don't. You're right. They just leave.
我确实觉得，你知道，在前台，你被困住了。如果有人走过来，对吧？凯文在早期几季会走到帕姆那里，靠在前台上聊天。哦，天哪，话痨，你走开了。好吧，我们还有另一个有趣的背景细节，来自不列颠哥伦比亚省兰利的维多利亚·S。她说在8分05秒时，我注意到帕姆或迈克尔离开迈克尔的公寓时没有锁门。为什么电影里总是这样，还是故意的？嗯，你知道，我重看的时候发现，他们确实没锁。你是对的。他们就那样走了。
And I thought maybe though my front door locks automatically.
I mean, you're right. That can happen. I actually changed the lock on my front door because we got
locked out so many times. Oh, so you have to lock it with a key. We have to lock it.
Okay. Yeah, but like, just to say, they do not deadbolt it or anything. And I think that's
for sake of time in the episode. Like, we did just have to get out the door. Like, we didn't have
the time to do the business of getting out our keys and locking it, the authenticity of leaving.
Right, right. I mean, that happens a lot in movies and TV. Like, you just hop out of a car. You don't
even take off a seatbelt or something, you know? It's like...
我以为，虽然我的前门会自动上锁。我是说，你是对的。这种情况可能会发生。我其实换了前门的锁，因为我们被锁在外面太多次了。哦，所以你必须用钥匙锁门。我们必须锁上。好的。是的，但就像，只是说，他们没有用防盗锁之类的东西。我认为这是为了剧集的节奏。就像，我们确实必须得出门。我们没有时间去拿钥匙和锁门，那种离开的真实感。对，对。我是说，电影和电视里经常发生这种情况。就像，你刚从车里跳出来。你甚至没解开安全带之类的，你知道吗？就像……
Well, it's also how no one says goodbye.
They never finish a phone call.
Oh, yeah.
Like, when you're done talking to someone on the phone in a movie, you just, like, go away.
It's so funny.
Like, it takes me forever to get off of a phone call.
I'm like, okay, well, anyway, I guess I'll talk to you soon.
And yeah, have a good time.
嗯，还有就是没人说再见。他们从不结束通话。哦，是的。就像，在电影里当你和某人通完电话时，你只是，就像，走开了。太搞笑了。就像，我挂断电话要花好久。我会说，好的，好吧，总之，我想我很快会再和你谈。然后，是的，祝你玩得开心。
Okay, bye.
Like that, you never get that in the movies either.
I want to see that in movies.
Right?
I want someone to do that.
I know.
I did think about you, though, Jenna, as you were talking about the business of locking
好的，再见。好的，再见。像那样，你在电影里也永远看不到。我想在电影里看到那个。对吧？我想让某人那样做。我知道。不过，珍娜，当你在谈论锁门这件事时，我确实想到了你。
the door.
Because I feel like if you were in a play, you would do that because it would ground you to the
realness.
When I saw you in the play Ashland Avenue in Chicago and you were so good in it, but you had to go over
and get yourself a cup of coffee and you did all of it.
You actually did the business.
Even there was like a sink that you would go and you actually did all the things.
Yeah.
因为我觉得如果你在演戏，你会那样做，因为它会让你回归现实。当我在芝加哥看你演的《阿什兰大道》时，你演得太好了，但你必须走过去给自己倒杯咖啡，你把所有动作都做了。你真的做了那些琐事。甚至那里有个水槽，你走过去，你真的做了所有的事情。是的。
I mean, I like doing all the business.
I do find it really great.
grounding. And like maybe to the point where, like, I have a thing that I'm always pitching
whenever I have a role. And what is it? Your face just lit up. Well, here's the thing.
It really bugs me, like, especially if you're playing a parent and you have to, like, walk
up or down stairs or walk from room to room in a scene. I'm sorry, if you are a parent, you are
constantly carrying something in your hand. It's true. Right? Like, if you're at the bottom of the
stairs, you collect stuff and you carry it up the stairs, and then vice versa. Like,
我是说，我喜欢做所有的琐事。我确实觉得这非常棒。让人脚踏实地。也许到了这种程度，比如，我每次接到角色时都会推销一个点子。是什么？你的脸刚才亮了起来。好吧，是这样的。这真的很困扰我，特别是如果你扮演一个父母，你必须在场景中走上或走下楼梯，或者从一个房间走到另一个房间。抱歉，如果你是一个父母，你手里总是拿着东西。这是真的。对吧？就像，如果你在楼梯底部，你会收集东西并把它们带上楼，反之亦然。就像，
cups and bowls. Cups and bowls. I'm always carrying them from downstairs.
That would be my pitch. Like, I should not be walking empty-handed down the stairs as I'm ready
to go out the door. Like, there's business. You need the business of life because also,
we're all trying to make as few trips as possible. So that's my other thing. Like, if someone is
carrying plates in from the table, don't give them two plates. Give them a pile of plates and they're
using the, they're using their knee to open the door. Like, that's life. So I love that business.
And of course, you know, I don't know. They're just like, please. I don't need your specificity.
And I'm like, well, I think it would be welcome. I can't wait to go see you in a play and watch you
杯子和碗。杯子和碗。我总是把它们从楼下拿上来。这就是我的推销点。就像，我不应该空手走下楼梯，准备出门。就像，有琐事要做。你需要生活的琐事，因为同样，我们都在尽量减少往返次数。所以这是我的另一件事。就像，如果有人从桌子上拿盘子进来，不要只给他们两个盘子。给他们一堆盘子，他们会用膝盖去开门。就像，这就是生活。所以我喜欢那些琐事。当然，你知道，我不知道。他们只是说，拜托。我不需要你的具体细节。而我会说，嗯，我觉得这会很受欢迎。我迫不及待地想去看你演戏，看着你
carry a bunch of stuff down some stairs. Okay. We have one last letter.
and it's from Caitlin M. in Norfolk, Virginia.
And I thought this was really sweet, and I wanted to share it.
Caitlin says, hi, office ladies.
One of my favorite moments from this episode is when Pam and Michael are talking in the driveway
toward the end of the episode.
This scene shows how Michael can be a great communicator.
After Pam's management of their day, comforting Michael, setting realistic goals, etc.,
搬一堆东西下楼梯。好的。我们还有最后一封信。来自弗吉尼亚州诺福克的凯特琳·M。我觉得这非常贴心，我想分享一下。凯特琳说，嗨，办公室女士们。这一集中我最喜欢的时刻之一是帕姆和迈克尔在剧集快结束时在车道上交谈。这一幕展示了迈克尔如何成为一个伟大的沟通者。在帕姆管理他们的一天、安慰迈克尔、设定现实目标等之后，
she has a vulnerable moment and out of frustration makes a hurtful comment.
Michael takes a moment to process it, steals his nerves,
and decides not to respond directly. Instead, he calmly explains their situation in simple terms,
provides a relevant personal anecdote that inspires her confidence, and explains which actions
he will take to remedy the situation. This takes the onus off of Pam to make decisions and or
take action while she's feeling acutely distressed, just like she did for Michael earlier that day.
I loved the scene so much. Michael was focused, firm, constructive, and empathetic.
scenes like these where his emotional intelligence shines through really balance him out as a
她有一个脆弱的时刻，出于沮丧发表了伤人的评论。迈克尔花了一点时间来消化它，稳住情绪，决定不直接回应。相反，他冷静地用简单的术语解释了他们的情况，提供了一个相关的个人轶事来激发她的信心，并解释了他将采取哪些行动来补救这种情况。这减轻了帕姆在感到极度痛苦时做出决定和/或采取行动的负担，就像她那天早些时候为迈克尔所做的那样。我非常喜欢这一幕。迈克尔专注、坚定、建设性且富有同理心。像这样展现他情商的场景真的让他作为一个
character. Thank you for making this wonderful podcast. You're a bright spot in my busy days as a
medical student in clerkships. Oh, thank you. I love hearing how that scene landed on Caitlin.
I know. And just what the show means to people throughout their day, you know, and how they hear it
and listen to it and process it. Well, thank you, everybody, for writing in. You can write
to us in our second drinks folder over on officeladys.com. And now here is your second drink of
dream team. I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on the office together. And we're
best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week,
we will break down an episode of the office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only
角色更加平衡。感谢你们制作这个精彩的播客。作为一名正在实习的医学生，你们是我忙碌日子里的亮点。哦，谢谢。我很高兴听到凯特琳对那一幕的感受。我知道。以及这部剧对人们日常生活的意义，你知道，他们如何听到、收听并消化它。好吧，谢谢大家的来信。你们可以写信到我们officeladys.com上的“第二杯”文件夹。现在是你们的第二杯《梦之队》。我是珍娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金赛。我们一起出演了《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为你们进行终极《办公室》重温播客。每周，我们都会拆解一集《办公室》，并提供只有
two people who were there can tell you. We're the office ladies. Hi. Lady, I want you to look
at me. I am looking at you and the first thing I said when I sat down was I love this top. What is this?
I said I'm going to bring it up. It is a sweatshirt. But look, it has poofies. Poofy shoulders.
Is that a hood? It's a poofy, shouldered, hooded sweatshirt. Remember, I told you, these poofy things are back.
This is true. Jenna went to the mall yesterday and she was texting me pictures of what I can only describe as Angela Martin's dream wardrobe.
Yes, it's lacy, high neck, what?
Poofy shoulders, poofy arms, when we do our book tour.
We're going to be dressing this way.
两个亲历者才能告诉你们的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女士。嗨。女士，我要你看着我。我正在看着你，我坐下时说的第一句话就是我喜欢这件上衣。这是什么？我说我要提一下。这是一件运动衫。但看，它有蓬蓬感。蓬蓬的肩膀。那是兜帽吗？这是一件蓬蓬肩、带兜帽的运动衫。记住，我告诉过你，这些蓬蓬的东西又流行回来了。这是真的。珍娜昨天去了商场，她给我发了照片，我只能将其描述为安吉拉·马丁的梦想衣橱。是的，蕾丝、高领，什么？蓬蓬肩、蓬蓬袖，当我们进行新书巡回宣传时。我们会这样穿。
And I will also have, you know, speaking of our book tour wardrobe, remember I said I was going to bring back the giant cloth flower.
Yeah.
That I don't know why I have so many in my closet.
It was a thing.
I was watching Drew Barrymore's talk show last week.
She was wearing one.
No.
I took a picture.
而且我还会，你知道，说到我们的新书巡回宣传服装，记得我说过我要带回巨大的布花吗？是的。我不知道为什么我的衣橱里有那么多。那曾经很流行。我上周在看德鲁·巴里摩尔的脱口秀。她戴着一个。不。我拍了张照片。
What?
On her blouse?
Yeah, her shirt.
She had a faky flower.
Oh, I need to see it.
Mark my words.
I am on trend.
It's poofy sleeves and faky flowers.
什么？在她的衬衫上？是的，她的衬衫。她戴了一朵假花。哦，我需要看看。记住我的话。我走在潮流前沿。是蓬蓬袖和假花。
2022, they're coming at you.
It's all happening, guys.
Angela Martin Fashion is here.
Mixed in with a little Jenna Fisher.
A lot of people wrote in to say the faky flower was from sex in the city.
I guess Carrie Bradshaw loved a faky flower.
She is not the OG of the faky flower.
Who is?
2022年，它们向你走来了。伙计们，一切都在发生。安吉拉·马丁时尚来了。混合了一点珍娜·费舍尔的风格。很多人写信说假花来自《欲望都市》。我猜凯莉·布拉德肖很喜欢假花。她可不是假花的鼻祖。那是谁？
I mean, I can't even tell you how much mail we got about it.
I mean, I feel like faky flower was here in the 80s.
Let's look up some Molly Ringwald.
Come on.
I'm with you there.
Yeah.
I'm positive I had a faky flower.
I clipped on a hat because I was trying to be like,
我是说，我甚至无法告诉你们我们收到了多少关于它的邮件。我是说，我觉得假花在80年代就有了。让我们查查莫莉·林沃德。拜托。我同意你的看法。是的。我肯定我有一朵假花。我把它别在帽子上，因为我试图变得像，
what was that movie Pretty and Bink?
I have decided that I'm going to single-handedly bring back the faky flower during our book tour.
Mm-hmm.
Even though Drew Barrymore wore one on her show, I'm going to bring it wide in 2022.
bring it wise. Yeah, I am. That should be our book tour slogan. Bring it wide. No. You know what?
I don't. Let's rethink that. We should not. You know what? I'm going to think on it. Okay. Bring your flower. No.
Well, maybe. No. We'll see you on the book tour.
But for today, we're going to be discussing Dream Team, which is Season 5, Episode 20 of The Office, written by B.J. Novak and directed by Paul Feig.
那部电影《红粉佳人》是什么？我已经决定，在我们的新书巡回宣传期间，我要凭一己之力带回假花。嗯。尽管德鲁·巴里摩尔在她的节目中戴了一朵，但我要在2022年把它带回来。带回来。是的，我要。那应该是我们的新书巡回宣传口号。带回来。不。你知道吗？我不。让我们重新考虑一下。我们不应该。你知道吗？我会考虑一下。好的。带上你的花。不。嗯，也许吧。不。我们巡回宣传见。但今天，我们要讨论《梦之队》，这是《办公室》第五季第20集，由B.J.诺瓦克编剧，保罗·费格执导。
Let's have a summary.
Here it is.
Michael has officially left under Mifflin,
and he has started his own paper company called Michael Scott Paper Company in his condo.
Pam has joined him.
Michael is having a little trouble facing his workday,
but with Pam's encouragement,
he decides to assemble a dream team to get their company started,
让我们来总结一下。就是这样。迈克尔正式离开了邓德·米夫林，他在他的公寓里创办了自己的造纸公司，叫迈克尔·斯科特造纸公司。帕姆加入了他的行列。迈克尔在面对工作日时遇到了一点困难，但在帕姆的鼓励下，他决定组建一个梦之队来启动他们的公司，
and they are also going to have a meeting with a potential investor.
Things are looking up.
Yeah.
Meanwhile, back at the thing,
the office, Charles is in charge. Charles in charge. I know. In Scranton.
Andy discovers that Charles is a soccer fan and now everybody is trying to kiss up to Charles
and get on his good side. It's the first time we've seen the man smile. Jim is even going to
pretend that he used to play soccer. This does not go well. No. You know what I loved about the storyline
他们还要和一位潜在投资者开会。情况正在好转。是的。与此同时，回到那个地方，办公室，查尔斯负责。查尔斯负责。我知道。在斯克兰顿。安迪发现查尔斯是个足球迷，现在每个人都在试图讨好查尔斯，争取他的好感。这是我们第一次看到这个人微笑。吉姆甚至要假装他以前踢过足球。这进行得并不顺利。不。你知道我喜欢这条故事线的什么吗？
and it's something BJ talked about in the DVD commentary for this episode? He said normally when you
break a story, you have the A story, which is the main story, and then you have the B story,
which is sort of like the other sort of side dish, if you will. He said that Idris's scenes were so
great, and the dynamic that Charles Minor had with the rest of the office was so interesting
for them. They really felt like his storyline as two A stories. It felt like that. Yeah.
Yeah, this felt like a very well-balanced episode. Right. I thought that was interesting.
Fast fact number one, this episode starts a delightful arc where Michael is going to run his own paper company.
And I found out that it was our writer Charlie Grandy who came up with this idea and they had been planning this arc for months.
这是B.J.在这一集的DVD评论中谈到的事情？他说通常当你拆解一个故事时，你有A故事，也就是主线故事，然后你有B故事，也就是配菜，如果你愿意的话。他说伊德里斯的场景太棒了，查尔斯·迈纳与办公室其他人的互动对他们来说非常有趣。他们真的觉得他的故事线就像两个A故事。感觉确实如此。是的。是的，这感觉像是一集非常平衡的剧集。对。我觉得这很有趣。速记事实第一条，这一集开启了一个令人愉快的篇章，迈克尔将经营自己的造纸公司。我发现这是我们的编剧查理·格兰迪想出的主意，他们几个月来一直在计划这个篇章。
Oh, well, he was on the DVD commentary for this episode.
I don't know if they mentioned this on the commentary, but this episode was nominated for an Emmy for outstanding single camera editing for a comedy series.
Our editors were nominated.
That's fantastic.
It was edited by Claire Scanlan.
Now, Claire came in to replace Dean Holland when he moved over to work as an editor and eventually a director on Parks and Recreation.
So now our two editors were Dave Rogers and Claire Scanlan.
You might remember Claire because she had a cameo as Freckles in Lecture Circuit Part 2.
哦，好吧，他在这一集的DVD评论中。我不知道他们在评论中是否提到了这一点，但这一集获得了艾美奖喜剧类剧集最佳单机位剪辑提名。我们的剪辑师被提名了。太棒了。它由克莱尔·斯坎伦剪辑。现在，克莱尔接替了迪恩·霍兰德，因为他转去《公园与游憩》担任剪辑师并最终成为导演。所以现在我们的两位剪辑师是戴夫·罗杰斯和克莱尔·斯坎伦。你们可能记得克莱尔，因为她在《讲座巡回第二部分》中客串了雀斑。
Before this, she edited Golden Ticket.
But Dream Team was her second episode, and she was nominated for.
for an Emmy, Claire.
Claire.
Of course now, Claire is like big, badass director, amazing.
I would love to have Claire on.
We should have Claire on.
I know.
在此之前，她剪辑了《金奖券》。但《梦之队》是她的第二集，她就被提名了。艾美奖，克莱尔。克莱尔。当然现在，克莱尔是大导演，太棒了。我很想请克莱尔来。我们应该请克莱尔来。我知道。
Fast fact number two is a location breakdown.
I knew you'd have one.
Well, a good deal of this episode takes place at Michael's condo.
And this was not an easy feat.
Randy Cordray told me we went back to the same condo complex where we shot Michael's
condo before for dinner party and pretty much any episode featuring Michael's condo. It was in
receipt of California. And it was owned now by a married couple. In order to use their condo,
we had to move them into a hotel for an entire week. Okay. We had to take all of their stuff out.
速记事实第二条是地点拆解。我就知道你会有的。嗯，这一集很大一部分发生在迈克尔的公寓。这可不是一件容易的事。兰迪·科德雷告诉我，我们回到了之前拍摄迈克尔公寓的同一个公寓大楼，用于《晚宴》和几乎所有以迈克尔公寓为特色的剧集。它在加利福尼亚州的收据里。现在由一对已婚夫妇拥有。为了使用他们的公寓，我们不得不把他们搬进酒店整整一周。好的。我们不得不把他们所有的东西都搬出来。
They put it into cartons in the garage. We painted the entire downstairs and decorated it.
They made a point to decorate it differently from dinner party because, you know, now Michael is single.
Yes, I noticed the only thing that remained that I recognized from dinner party was the St. Pauli Girl beer sign.
Same in the dining room.
Yes.
We only shot at this condo for one day, and then they had to completely restore it back to the way the couple had it.
And here is the thing that is fascinating to me, because what they would do is they would take like a gazillion photos.
Yeah.
他们把东西装进车库的纸箱里。我们粉刷了整个楼下并进行了装饰。他们特意装饰得与《晚宴》不同，因为，你知道，现在迈克尔单身了。是的，我注意到我从《晚宴》中认出的唯一剩下的东西是圣保利女孩啤酒招牌。餐厅里也是。是的。我们只在这个公寓拍了一天，然后他们必须完全把它恢复成那对夫妇原来的样子。这里有一件事让我着迷，因为他们会做的是他们会拍像一万亿张照片。是的。
Of every shelf, of everything.
Anything that we moved, they took a picture of it before they moved it, and they would put it in a binder.
Like hard copy photos, because back then, you know, that's what it was.
Yeah, so it would be like kitchen counter.
Yes.
So that when the people came back, like even their little spoon caddy was where they left it.
Or if they had a bookshelf, all their stuff, the books were in the same order as before.
The picture frames were right where they left them.
每一层架子，每一件东西。任何我们移动的东西，他们在移动前都拍了照，然后把它们放在一个活页夹里。就像纸质照片，因为那时，你知道，就是那样。是的，所以它会像厨房台面。是的。所以当人们回来时，甚至他们的小勺子架都在他们离开的地方。或者如果他们有书架，他们所有的东西，书的顺序和以前一样。相框就在他们离开的地方。
Everything.
Isn't that fascinating?
I know. It is amazing. In the DVD commentary, BJ talked about how carefully they decorated every wall. They put so much thought in detail and you just see it just quickly in the background. But I caught a few things. I'm sure you guys did too. I'm going to bring them up when we get to it. I love it. Fast fact number three is a guest star homage to the amazing actress who played Nana. Her name is Connie Sawyer. Just incredible.
We got a piece of mail from Meredith Q who wrote,
I did a deep dive.
The woman who played Nana needs some recognition.
Yes, she does.
一切。一切。这不迷人吗？我知道。这太神奇了。在DVD评论中，B.J.谈到了他们装饰每一面墙是多么小心。他们投入了如此多的思考和细节，你只是在背景中快速看到它。但我捕捉到了一些东西。我相信你们也捕捉到了。当我们讲到那里时，我会提出来。我喜欢它。速记事实第三条是对扮演娜娜的伟大女演员的客串致敬。她的名字是康妮·索耶。简直不可思议。我们收到了一封来自梅雷迪思·Q的邮件，她写道，我做了一次深入研究。扮演娜娜的女人需要得到认可。是的，她需要。
First of all, she lived to be 105.
Who does that?
Wow.
Is what Meredith said.
And according to IMDB, her first acting credit was in 1953 at the age of 40.
Her last acting credit was in 2014 at the age of 101.
That's 61 years of acting plus she.
She acted over the age of 100.
首先，她活到了105岁。谁能做到这一点？哇。这是梅雷迪思说的。根据IMDB，她的第一个表演作品是在1953年，当时40岁。她的最后一个表演作品是在2014年，当时101岁。那是61年的表演生涯，而且她。她在100岁之后还在表演。
What a rock star.
Tell me everything.
Well, I looked into this woman.
Mm-hmm.
And performance had been a part of her life, her whole life.
She had done vaudeville.
She had performed live with Frank Sinatra.
But it's true that she never had a film or television role until she was 40.
真是个摇滚明星。告诉我一切。嗯，我研究了这个女人。嗯。表演一直是他生活的一部分，她的一生。她做过杂耍表演。她曾与弗兰克·辛纳屈现场表演。但确实，直到40岁她才获得电影或电视角色。
So on the commentary, the writers were talking about her on set.
They said she had the most amazing stories.
She was throwing out stories about Bing Crosby, Bob Hope,
They were just like, oh my gosh, she was fascinating.
What I love about her story, Jenna, is that she did stage shows for years.
She didn't get an on-camera role till 40, but this was her passion.
And you should never let anyone take that away from you.
However, your passion manifests itself, I just love her story.
所以在评论中，编剧们在片场谈论她。他们说她有最神奇的故事。她抛出关于平·克劳斯贝、鲍勃·霍普的故事，他们就像，哦天哪，她太迷人了。我喜欢她的故事的一点是，珍娜，她多年来一直做舞台表演。她直到40岁才获得镜头前的角色，但这一直是她的热情所在。你永远不应该让任何人从你手中夺走它。无论你的热情如何体现，我只是喜欢她的故事。
She just kept at it.
She has over 140 acting credits, and almost all of them are small roles.
And she has this quote about her acting career where she said,
life is fun.
That has nothing to do with whether you become a star or not.
And if the parts aren't too large, I can go around talking to everybody.
It's like going to a party.
Aw.
她只是坚持了下来。她有超过140个表演作品，几乎所有都是小角色。她有一句关于她演艺生涯的名言，她说，生活很有趣。这与你是否成为明星无关。如果角色不是太大，我可以到处和每个人聊天。就像去参加聚会一样。啊。
And when she was 104, she wrote an autobiography called,
I never wanted to be a star and I wasn't.
And she self-published it in 2017.
At 104.
Wow.
That is amazing.
BJ said the scenes that you guys did,
with her that when they threw out some improv, she didn't miss a beat.
当她104岁时，她写了一本自传，叫《我从不想成为明星，我也不是》。她在2017年自费出版了它。104岁。哇。这太神奇了。B.J.说你们和她一起拍的场景，当他们抛出一些即兴表演时，她一点也没掉链子。
Well, I remember her from when Harry met Sally.
She is one of the women in the couples that they interview documentary style.
Yes. Yes.
She has no lines.
Her husband speaks the whole time, but it all plays out on her face.
And she is so good.
And she has this story where she says that she read the script.
And she went to Rob Reiner and she said, I want to be the woman in the deli who says the famous
嗯，我记得她在《当哈利遇到莎莉》里的表演。她是他们以纪录片风格采访的夫妇中的女性之一。是的。是的。她没有台词。她的丈夫一直在说话，但这一切都表现在她的脸上。她演得太好了。她有一个故事，她说她读了剧本。她去找罗伯·莱纳，她说，我想成为熟食店里那个说出那句名言的女人，
line, I'll have what she's having. She said, I want the show stopping line. And he said, I'm sorry,
we already shot that. My mother did it. Yeah, his mom did it. But she's just so good. She passed away in
2018 at the age of 105. And at the time of her death, she was the oldest working actress in
Hollywood and the oldest member of the Screen Actress Guild Union. Amazing woman. Amazing. Connie Sawyer,
everybody. Well, that's all I've got for fast facts. But before we go to break,
You know, Marcus York, who played Billy Merchant, is in this episode.
This is his last appearance on the show.
And he actually passed away earlier this year.
“我也要她点的那个”。她说，我想要那句抢镜的台词。他说，抱歉，我们已经拍完了。我妈妈演的。是的，他妈妈演的。但她真的太好了。她于2018年去世，享年105岁。在她去世时，她是好莱坞最年长的在职女演员，也是演员工会最年长的成员。了不起的女人。了不起。康妮·索耶，各位。好吧，这就是我所有的速记事实。但在我们休息之前，你知道，扮演比利·商人的马库斯·约克在这一集中。这是他在剧中的最后一次露面。他其实在今年早些时候去世了。
He was just wonderful.
And he was so wonderful to us.
He shared a story with us.
He did.
He and I would text, and we talked on the phone several times.
He loved his character of Billy Merchant.
He was so supportive of the show.
And we were just so fond of him.
他真是太棒了。他对我们太好了。他与我们分享了一个故事。他确实分享了。我和他会发短信，我们打过几次电话。他喜欢他扮演的比利·商人这个角色。他非常支持这部剧。我们非常喜欢他。
We got a letter from a man named Nathan N.
and I thought this summed up Marcus pretty well. He said,
I just wanted to comment on Marcus York, because I believe this is his last episode,
and I wanted to let people know what kind of guy he is. He was from Dark County, Ohio,
which is near where I work as a police officer. Just so happens that my partner met him one night
when he was checking on him when he pulled over to use his phone. Upon Marcus telling him he was
on the office, my partner said that he's never watched the show.
but that I did and I was going to be so bummed that I missed him because I've talked about him
我们收到了一封来自内森·N的男人的信，我觉得这很好地总结了马库斯。他说，我只是想评论一下马库斯·约克，因为我相信这是他的最后一集，我想让人们知道他是什么样的人。他来自俄亥俄州的达克县，离我作为警察工作的地方很近。碰巧我的搭档有一天晚上在检查他时遇到了他，当时他靠边停车打电话。在马库斯告诉他他出演了《办公室》后，我的搭档说他从来没看过这部剧。但我看过，如果我错过了他，我会非常沮丧，因为我谈论过他
in the past. Marcus asked him if I was working and he said I wouldn't be in for about an hour.
Not only did Marcus wait that hour, but on top of that, he took a picture with me, his idea,
hung out for an hour, and gave me an autographed picture made out to my wife. He seemed so happy
to meet a fan that knew him and was interested in him and his career. Even though I only met him
that one time, he definitely left a lasting impression for sure, such a nice guy and a tragic loss.
That is so well said. He was such a nice person. And he was so aware of the joy that he could
bring to people by just being open to that fan experience or talking about his time on the show.
And he certainly did that with us here at office ladies. He did. Much love to Marcus and his family.
过去。马库斯问他我是否在工作，他说我还要一个小时才上班。马库斯不仅等了那一个小时，而且最重要的是，他和我拍了一张照片，这是他的主意，待了一个小时，还给了我一张写给我妻子的亲笔签名照片。他似乎很高兴见到一个认识他并对他和他的职业生涯感兴趣的粉丝。虽然我只见过他那一次，但他确实留下了深刻的印象，真是个好人，也是一个悲剧性的损失。说得太好了。他真是个好人。他非常清楚，通过对粉丝体验保持开放态度或谈论他在剧中的时光，他能给人们带来快乐。他确实在《办公室女士》这里做到了。他做到了。向马库斯和他的家人致以深切的爱。
All right. Let's go to break. Let's do it. Every week on the Moth podcast, you'll hear
true stories that will intrigue you, inspire you, and make you laugh. When I was 14 years old,
I had a deeply meaningful experience, something so real that I knew it was going to shape who
I was to become for the rest of my life. I saw the spice girls on MTV. For real stories,
live on stage, from astronauts, accountants, comedians, farmers, and people just like you,
follow and listen to The Moth wherever you get your podcasts. Well, we are back from break, and before we get
into Dream Team, I couldn't help but remember the OG Dream Team, Jenna.
Was it basketball?
好了。让我们休息一下。开始吧。每周在Moth播客上，你都会听到引人入胜、鼓舞人心并让你发笑的真实故事。当我14岁时，我经历了一次意义深远的体验，如此真实，以至于我知道它将塑造我余生要成为的人。我在MTV上看到了辣妹组合。想听真实故事，现场直播，来自宇航员、会计师、喜剧演员、农民和像你一样的人，请在任何你获取播客的地方关注并收听The Moth。好吧，我们休息回来了，在进入《梦之队》之前，我忍不住想起了最初的梦之队，珍娜。是篮球吗？
Yes.
You guys, the 1992 United States Men's Olympic Basketball Team nicknamed the Dream Team.
It was the first American Olympic team to feature active professional players from the National
Basketball Association.
And the team has been described from journalists around the world as the greatest sports team
ever assembled.
Wow.
是的。是的。伙计们，1992年美国男子奥运篮球队，绰号梦之队。这是第一支拥有来自美国国家篮球协会的现役职业球员的美国奥运代表队。这支球队被世界各地的记者描述为有史以来组建的最伟大的运动队。哇。
I know.
I mean, I totally remember that.
Me too.
It was a big deal.
It was a big deal, you guys.
And listen, this is like when I was in school.
So when this episode was coming up, whenever I saw the title Dream Team, I just always think.
That's what I think of, too.
我知道。我是说，我完全记得那个。我也是。那是一件大事。那是一件大事，伙计们。听着，这就像我在学校的时候。所以当这一集要播出时，每当我看到《梦之队》这个标题，我总是会想到那个。这也是我所想到的。
Yeah.
I don't know if you guys think of that.
But I just want to read the roster and just a few stats, okay, of this team.
All right.
The full roster for the 1992 Dream Team was Charles Barkley, Larry Bird, Patrick Ewing, Magic
Johnson, Michael Jordan, Carl Malone, Chris Mullen, Scotty Pippin, David.
Robinson, John Stockton. Then they added two players later, Clyde Drexler, and they included one collegiate
player, Christian Leitner, of Duke University, who was chosen over Louisiana State University's
是的。我不知道你们是否会想到那个。但我只是想读一下名单和一些统计数据，好吗，关于这支球队。好的。1992年梦之队的完整名单是查尔斯·巴克利、拉里·伯德、帕特里克·尤因、魔术师约翰逊、迈克尔·乔丹、卡尔·马龙、克里斯·穆林、斯科蒂·皮蓬、大卫·罗宾逊、约翰·斯托克顿。后来他们又增加了两名球员，克莱德·德雷克斯勒，他们包括了一名大学球员，杜克大学的克里斯蒂安·莱特纳，他被选中超过了路易斯安那州立大学的
Shaquille O'Neal. Wow. Yeah. Head coach was Chuck Daly. Here are some things I thought were fun.
The co-captains of the team were Larry Bird and Magic Johnson. They were undefeated in the Olympics.
Chuck Daly used zero timeouts for the entire eight games.
Not a single timeout was called, which is wild to me.
Larry Bird was the oldest member of the dream team, and guess how old he was?
He was the oldest member of the dream team.
41.
35.
沙奎尔·奥尼尔。哇。是的。主教练是查克·戴利。这里有一些我觉得有趣的事情。球队的联合队长是拉里·伯德和魔术师约翰逊。他们在奥运会上保持不败。查克·戴利在整整八场比赛中没有使用过一次暂停。一次暂停都没有叫过，这对我来说太疯狂了。拉里·伯德是梦之队中最年长的成员，猜猜他多大？他是梦之队中最年长的成员。41岁。35岁。
Wow.
That was the old guy.
And I thought this was interesting.
Guess who led the dream team in scoring?
I'm going to admit here that I don't watch basketball.
And I don't know anything about basketball.
So I know these people's names, and I know that they played basketball.
Okay, okay.
哇。那是老家伙。我觉得这很有趣。猜猜谁是梦之队的得分王？我在这里承认我不看篮球。我对篮球一无所知。所以我知道这些人的名字，我知道他们打篮球。好的，好的。
Well, I would have guessed Michael Jordan.
Who shoots the most?
Wouldn't you have guessed Michael Jordan, Sam, Cassie?
He's a good player.
He's amazing.
Watch the Last Dance documentary.
Amazing.
I would have guessed Michael Jordan, but in fact, it was Charles Barkley, and Michael Jordan came in second.
嗯，我会猜迈克尔·乔丹。谁投篮最多？你难道不会猜迈克尔·乔丹吗，萨姆，卡西？他是个好球员。他太棒了。看《最后之舞》纪录片。太棒了。我会猜迈克尔·乔丹，但事实上，是查尔斯·巴克利，迈克尔·乔丹排在第二。
Oh.
How about them apples?
But anyway, when I think of Dream Team, I think of the OG Dream Team.
But you know, Jenna, this isn't the only time in the course of our show that we mention the dream team.
When else do we mention the dream team?
Bonus points, if you can guess this.
The dream team and Meredith.
I mean, I'm assuming it's a party planning thing, but I don't know what episode that's from.
哦。那又怎么样呢？但总之，当我想到梦之队时，我会想到最初的梦之队。但你知道，珍娜，这不是我们在节目过程中唯一一次提到梦之队。我们还在什么时候提到过梦之队？如果你能猜到这个，加分。梦之队和梅雷迪思。我是说，我假设这是派对策划的事情，但我不知道那是哪一集。
The Dream Team and Meredith is from, some of you out there probably guess this, season seven, goodbye Michael.
Oh!
And it was about the party planning committee. It's Angela, Phyllis, and Pam, and then Meredith kind of pops her head in the back. Are we planning the goodbye party for Michael? Is that what's going to happen? I think so. All right. So, Dream Team, two of them in the course of the office. One is Michael Scott Paper Company, which is Vikram, Pam, Ryan and Michael. And the other is the party planning committee. Well, let's get into this episode, Jen, because phones are ringing. Kevin's at reception. It's not going well.
He's trying so hard to transfer these calls.
I mean, he's just yelling across the office rather than transfer the calls because he can't remember everyone's extension.
And he's sort of feeling personal stuff like it cracked me up that Oscar's mom was calling.
Yes.
He yelled it across the bullpen.
梦之队和梅雷迪思来自，你们中的一些人可能猜到了，第七季，再见迈克尔。哦！那是关于派对策划委员会的。是安吉拉、菲利斯和帕姆，然后梅雷迪思在后面探出头来。我们在为迈克尔策划告别派对吗？那是会发生的事吗？我想是的。好吧。所以，梦之队，在《办公室》过程中有两个。一个是迈克尔·斯科特造纸公司，也就是维克拉姆、帕姆、瑞安和迈克尔。另一个是派对策划委员会。好吧，让我们进入这一集，珍，因为电话响了。凯文在前台。情况不太妙。他非常努力地转接这些电话。我是说，他只是在办公室里大喊大叫，而不是转接电话，因为他不记得每个人的分机号。他甚至感觉到了个人的东西，奥斯卡的妈妈打电话让我笑死了。是的。他在大厅里喊了出来。
Well, he is going to try to transfer a call to Andy.
Yeah.
But first, he's going to transfer it to pretty much every other desk in the office.
He's going to run around and then transfer it and then transfer it and transfer it.
Yeah, like it goes to Creed and then it goes, he's just running all over the place.
We got a question from Brenda R in Mexico who wants to know, was Brian really transferring the phone calls on set?
Or was this some behind the scenes magic?
Well, when I would be Pam at the reception desk, they had a list of the real extensions because the phones really worked.
好吧，他要尝试把电话转给安迪。是的。但首先，他要把电话转给办公室里几乎所有的其他办公桌。他要跑来跑去，然后转接，然后转接，然后转接。是的，就像它转到了克里德那里，然后它转到了，他只是到处跑。我们收到了来自墨西哥的布伦达·R的问题，她想知道，布莱恩在片场真的在转接电话吗？还是这只是一些幕后魔法？嗯，当我作为帕姆在前台时，他们有一份真实分机号的列表，因为电话真的能用。
Yeah.
And I would really transfer the calls.
But the initial ring would come from somebody behind the scenes.
There was a desk with a phone that was also connected to our phones backstage.
So there were two options when you wanted to transfer a call.
Either you did it for real.
Or you would just hang up and the person backstage would make another person's phone ring.
But that would require them sort of trying to whisper into a walkie-talkie to get them to coordinate all that.
是的。我真的会转接电话。但最初的铃声会来自幕后的某个人。有一张桌子上有电话，也连接到我们后台的电话。所以当你想要转接电话时有两个选择。要么你真的做了。要么你只是挂断，后台的人会让另一个人的电话响。但这需要他们有点像对着对讲机耳语，让他们协调这一切。
Yeah.
So I always just transferred the calls.
I mean, I had my real-life receptionist experience.
Yeah.
I got to put it to use.
But I didn't know what Brian did.
So I texted him.
是的。所以我总是直接转接电话。我是说，我有我现实生活中的前台经验。是的。我得把它用上。是的。但我不知道布莱恩做了什么。所以我给他发了短信。
And he said he also really transferred the calls, but he would have to remember the extensions because he was running around.
After the first transfer, he couldn't take his slip of paper with him anymore.
Right.
Oh, my gosh.
I still have a photo of all of our transfer numbers that was taped to my phone.
Oh, wow.
Yeah.
Well, in the DVD commentary, Matt Sone, our camera operator, shared with us that on the day they were
他说他也真的转接了电话，但他必须记住分机号，因为他在跑来跑去。第一次转接后，他不能再带着他的纸条了。对。哦，天哪。我仍然有一张贴在我电话上的所有转接号码的照片。哦，哇。是的。嗯，在DVD评论中，我们的摄像师马特·索恩和我们分享说，在他们拍摄的那天，
filming, Brian was doing the transferring, but they were having some issues with the phones.
And so they weren't going to some of the desk clumps they were supposed to.
And so Brian actually ended up running around to wherever it was ringing.
Oh, wow.
So that mania was a little real.
He really didn't know where it was going to ring.
I think there's at least one time where it didn't ring where it was supposed to, and he just ran.
And Matt said they were just following him.
布莱恩在做转接，但电话出了一些问题。所以它们没有转到它们应该去的办公桌群。所以布莱恩实际上最终跑到了铃声响起的任何地方。哦，哇。所以那种狂躁有点真实。他真的不知道它会在哪里响。我想至少有一次它没有在应该响的地方响，他只是跑了。马特说他们只是跟着他。
We had a fan question from Monica in Scranton, Angela, and this one's for you.
Okay.
When Angela yells out, you're bad at this too.
Were you implying that Pam is bad at it and so is Kevin or that Kevin is bad at everything?
Well, first of all, that line is scripted.
That was not improv.
And I think Angela is just implying that Kevin is horrible at everything.
Okay.
我们有一个来自斯克兰顿莫妮卡的粉丝问题，安吉拉，这是给你的。好的。当安吉拉大喊“你也很烂”时，你是暗示帕姆很烂，凯文也很烂，还是凯文什么都烂？嗯，首先，那句台词是剧本写的。那不是即兴表演。而且我认为安吉拉只是暗示凯文什么都烂。好的。
I actually don't think it's a dig at Pam for once. I think it's more of a dig at Kevin.
We also got a piece of mail from Grace B, who said, Kevin taught me how to transfer a call.
She said she was an office aide in high school. They got a new phone system. She wasn't sure what to do, but she remembered this episode, transfer extension transfer, and it worked.
Oh my gosh. So she says thank you. You're welcome. Well, in the script, when Kevin finally,
gets the call to Andy, this was the stage direction. People ad lib, way to go, all right, applaud,
giving Kevin fist bumps. He is very happy. In the background of Andy's talking head, the celebration
continues, Kevin shakes up a soda can and opens it. That's very dream team-esque. I know. Very sports
celebration. I know. Well, now Pam is going to arrive for her first day of work. First day,
我其实不认为这是针对帕姆的挖苦。我觉得这更多是针对凯文的挖苦。我们还收到了一封来自格蕾丝·B的信，她说，凯文教我如何转接电话。她说她是高中的办公室助理。他们换了新的电话系统。她不知道该怎么办，但她记得这一集，转接分机转接，它成功了。哦，天哪。所以她说谢谢。不客气。嗯，在剧本中，当凯文终于把电话转给安迪时，这是舞台指导。人们即兴表演，干得好，太棒了，鼓掌，给凯文碰拳。他非常高兴。在安迪采访镜头的背景中，庆祝活动继续，凯文摇晃一个汽水罐并打开它。这非常有梦之队的风格。我知道。非常体育庆祝。我知道。好吧，现在帕姆要到达她工作的第一天了。第一天，
there's a sign and everything. I know. It's official.
I don't know if you noticed her little blazer.
I did.
There was a very big wardrobe discussion before we started this arc, yes.
For what Pam's I'm a paper salesman outfit is?
Yes.
So here's one thing.
We originally thought should she wear a pants suit, like kind of a power suit?
甚至还有个牌子。我知道。这是官方的。不知道你有没有注意到她那件小西装。我注意到了。在我们开始这一季之前，关于服装有过非常激烈的讨论，是的。是为了帕姆那身“我是个纸张推销员”的行头吗？是的。所以有一件事。我们最初想的是，她应该穿裤装吗，那种职场女强人的套装？
So bold, Pam.
But listen to this.
In an earlier season, there had been a discussion about if Pam could sometimes wear pants to the office.
Because she had such a uniform of her cardigan and her pencil skirt and everything.
And it went all the way up to the network.
And the network said, Pam must wear pencil skirts.
Yeah.
Okay.
太大胆了，帕姆。但听听这个。在更早的一季里，曾讨论过帕姆是否可以偶尔在办公室穿裤子。因为她总是穿着开衫配铅笔裙之类的制服。这事一直闹到了电视网高层。电视网说，帕姆必须穿铅笔裙。好吧。
I have wondered about this, Jenna.
And I've never told you this.
But for a few episodes, they put Angela Martin in dress pants.
And then all of a sudden the pants went away.
And so I went to wardrobe when I said, hey, can we bring back the dress pants?
Those are so comfortable.
And they said, oh, actually, we got a note that they just.
just want you in skirts.
我一直很好奇这件事，珍娜。我从来没跟你说过。但在几集里，他们让安吉拉·马丁穿了西裤。然后突然之间，裤子就不见了。所以我去找服装组说，嘿，我们能把西裤带回来吗？那些裤子太舒服了。他们说，哦，其实我们收到通知，他们就是……就是想让你穿裙子。
Isn't that interesting?
I did not know you got the same note.
I thought that was crazy.
And so we were reminded that I could not wear a pantsuit.
We had to keep the pencil skirt.
So only thing we could change was the top half of my body.
Who was the brass at the top of NBC that was like, Office Ladies Must Wear skirts?
Well, look at Phyllis, always in a skirt.
这难道不有趣吗？我不知道你也收到了同样的通知。我觉得这太疯狂了。所以我们被提醒我不能穿裤装。我们必须保留铅笔裙。所以我们唯一能改变的就是我上半身的穿着。当时NBC高层里是谁说“办公室女士必须穿裙子”的？好吧，看看菲利斯，总是穿着裙子。
Meredith, always in some kind of jumper.
Kelly.
Jan.
And Nellie.
skirts. However, Karen
always wore pants. I don't think she ever wore a skirt, and I think that
sometimes Holly wore pants. Am I right? But mostly, it was dresses and skirts.
梅雷迪思，总是穿着某种背带裙。凯利。凯利。简。还有内莉。都是裙子。然而，凯伦总是穿裤子。我不认为她穿过裙子，而且我觉得有时候霍莉也穿裤子。我说得对吗？但大多数情况下，都是连衣裙和裙子。
Joe Bennett wore pants. But those were all guest stars. Quora cast had to be in skirts,
I guess. I don't know. Who was the network brass at the time? Was it
the guy from Madman? Was Don Draper running the network? Is that who? Maybe. I fill a soapbox of
Come on. No, I'm going to leave it. Oh, leave it. Let's leave it. Everyone knows it. They heard it. They heard it. It was subtle. It was there. Okay, so bottom line is, here's what we did. I switched out my panty hose for tights. I'm wearing a little bit more of a heel, bit of a power shoe, and a blazer. So they were little changes, but they did feel impactful. I thought Pam felt a little more polished. Yeah. That was our goal. Well, Michael is going to start his first day of work in a bathrobe. Pam's like,
Michael, you were expecting me, weren't you?
He's like, yeah.
Yeah, she's like, are you wearing anything under the rope?
And he's like, that's inappropriate.
乔·贝内特穿过裤子。但那些都是客串明星。我想，核心演员必须穿裙子。我不知道。当时电视网的高层是谁？是《广告狂人》里的那个人吗？是唐·德雷珀在管理电视网吗？是他吗？也许吧。我本来想发表一番长篇大论。不，我还是算了吧。哦，算了吧。让我们算了吧。大家都知道。他们听到了。他们听到了。这很微妙。就在那儿。好吧，所以底线是，我们是这样做的。我把连裤袜换成了紧身裤。我穿了一双稍微高一点的跟鞋，一双更有气场的鞋，还有一件西装外套。所以这些都是小改动，但确实很有冲击力。我觉得帕姆看起来更干练了。是的。那是我们的目标。好吧，迈克尔要穿着浴袍开始他的第一天工作了。帕姆说，迈克尔，你在等我，对吧？他说，是的。是的，她说，你浴袍下面穿东西了吗？他说，这不合适。
He brings her inside, and he actually has set up his dining room, sort of office-like.
It's nice.
It is nice.
I think these are all items he took from the supply chest as he was leaving.
Clearly.
And he starts making French toast.
A lot of French toast.
And there was a deleted Pam talking head.
他把她带进屋，他实际上已经把他的餐厅布置得像个办公室一样。挺不错的。确实不错。我想这些都是他离开时从办公用品柜里拿走的东西。显然。然后他开始做法式吐司。做了很多法式吐司。还有一个被删减的帕姆的采访片段。
where she explains her motivation to join Michael.
She steps outside on the patio while he's making French toast.
Here it is.
I felt ready for a change.
After all these years at Dundermifflin,
I just wasn't getting the same rush that I used to get from being a receptionist.
This feels good.
This egg won't crack.
她解释了她加入迈克尔的动机。当他在做法式吐司时，她走到露台上。就是这个。我感觉准备好迎接改变了。在邓德米福林工作了这么多年后，我再也找不到以前做前台时那种冲动了。这种感觉很好。这个鸡蛋敲不开。
Oh, okay.
The egg won't crack.
Yeah, he interrupts her to help him crack eggs.
Pam enjoys her French toast.
It was very good.
I ate it.
Did you really?
It was delicious.
哦，好吧。鸡蛋敲不开。是的，他打断她，让她帮忙敲鸡蛋。帕姆很享受她的法式吐司。味道很好。我吃了。你真的吃了？很美味。
That was just real.
Way to go, prop food.
I know.
We had a fan question from Isla H.
Who had to make all the French toast?
Phil Shea and his team.
They made a bunch of French toast.
But here's the problem.
那可是真的。道具食物干得好。我知道。我们有一个来自艾拉·H的粉丝提问。是谁做了所有的法式吐司？菲尔·谢和他的团队。他们做了很多法式吐司。但问题来了。
Michael won't stop making French toast.
And Pam realizes it's because he's having some feelings about really getting started in this new company.
She tries to get him to stop mixing the eggs, and it ends up spilling eggs all over him.
All over him and into his crocs.
We got questions about that.
People wanted to know, was it real egg in the bowl?
Was the line, I have egg in my crocs improvised?
And people are also curious, how did we do this scene?
迈克尔不停地做法式吐司。帕姆意识到这是因为他在真正开始这家新公司时有些感触。她试图让他停止搅拌鸡蛋，结果鸡蛋洒了他一身。洒了他一身，还流进了他的洞洞鞋里。我们收到了关于这个的问题。人们想知道，碗里的是真鸡蛋吗？“我洞洞鞋里有鸡蛋”这句台词是即兴发挥的吗？人们也很好奇，我们是怎么拍这场戏的？
Because it seems difficult to have the egg go in the same place each time.
Well, I will say that Steve did improvise the line.
egg in my crocs. It was very hard not to laugh, but it's true. We couldn't get the egg to splash
in the same way every time, so I could not laugh because this was a oneer. We would have to use a
whole take. We couldn't cut between different takes because the egg would be different.
Oh, so much pressure. It's so hard to not laugh with Steve. I know. But I didn't, but I think you
can tell how hard I am trying not to laugh. Do you constipated or something? Yeah, I do. I look like,
You can tell him like tensely holding in.
因为每次让鸡蛋洒在同一个地方似乎很难。好吧，我会说史蒂夫确实即兴发挥了那句台词。“我洞洞鞋里有鸡蛋”。忍住不笑真的很难，但这是真的。我们无法让鸡蛋每次都以同样的方式溅出来，所以我不能笑，因为这是一镜到底。我们必须用掉整个拍摄过程。我们不能在不同的镜头之间剪辑，因为鸡蛋的状态会不同。哦，压力太大了。和史蒂夫一起拍戏真的很难不笑。我知道。但我没笑，但我认为你能看出我忍得有多辛苦。你便秘了吗还是怎么的？是的，我有。我看起来就像，你能看出我紧张地憋着。
It works though.
It just looks like Pam is like watching someone who she thinks is supposed to know what they're doing who clearly doesn't.
She's like, oh, crap, what have I gotten myself into?
Well, we did do several takes of this.
And it was a big reset every time because we would have to clean up all the eggs in the kitchen.
We'd have to clean up all the eggs on Steve.
He would have to change his bathrobe.
But this one was perfect.
不过效果很好。看起来就像帕姆在看着一个她认为应该知道自己在做什么，但显然根本不知道的人。她心想，哦，该死，我把自己卷进什么事里了？好吧，我们确实拍了好几次。每次都要重新准备，因为我们得清理厨房里所有的鸡蛋。我们得清理史蒂夫身上所有的鸡蛋。他得换掉他的浴袍。但这一条是完美的。
This was the time he improvised that line.
And the egg just went everywhere.
So I also knew as I was standing there, this is the one. Do not mess this up.
Right. So one thing to point out, you guys, which I love about our show, to nerd out on you for a minute, since Steve improvised the line, eggs and my crocs, that meant our camera operator had to improvise the move to pan down to his feet.
Yes.
That wouldn't have been planned, but that sells the joke.
So good.
Such a great two-hander.
这就是他即兴发挥那句台词的那一次。鸡蛋到处都是。所以我站在那里的时候也知道，就是这一条了。千万别搞砸。对。所以有一点要指出，伙计们，我喜欢我们剧的一点是，让我稍微卖弄一下，既然史蒂夫即兴说了那句“我洞洞鞋里有鸡蛋”，这意味着我们的摄像师必须即兴移动镜头去拍他的脚。是的。那不是计划好的，但那让笑点更突出了。太棒了。真是精彩的对手戏。
We also had a fan catch in this scene in the kitchen.
Sierra G and Lauren W point out that at four minutes 31 seconds, there's a sign on his kitchen
counter that says his.
Yeah.
But there is no hers.
Hers.
I saw that too.
And they were like, I guess Jan took the hers when she left.
我们在这个厨房场景中还有一个粉丝发现。塞拉·G和劳伦·W指出，在4分31秒时，他厨房台面上有一个牌子写着“他的”。是的。但没有“她的”。她的。我也看到了。他们说，我猜简离开时把“她的”带走了。
Or maybe she never even wanted hers out.
Maybe Michael just bought a his.
I think he bought a his, her, and she never put hers out.
I don't know.
It's sad no matter how it shook out.
Should we go back to the?
the office and see what's happening back there? Yes, because this was a really fun conference room scene.
We were having a absolute blast with Idris. He's holding court the way Michael used to, and he's telling
或者也许她根本没想把“她的”拿出来。也许迈克尔只是买了一个“他的”。我想他买了一个“他的”和“她的”，而她从来没把“她的”拿出来。我不知道。不管怎样，这都很悲伤。我们要回到办公室看看那里发生了什么吗？是的，因为这是一场非常有趣的会议室戏。我们和伊德里斯玩得非常开心。他像迈克尔以前那样主持会议，他正在告诉
them how things are going to proceed now that they've lost two employees. But Kelly and Angela just
want to know more about Charles. I love that Kelly's like, where are you staying in Scranton?
And he's like a hotel. And Angela goes, where were you born? Where were you born? It was so fun. It was hard not to
laugh. And I want you guys to know, when Andy asked how the operations of the company are going
in the background, I caught Brian out of character. He is clearly just Brian in this moment.
If you go to three minutes, two seconds, it's very subtle, but look at his face. That is Brian
and not Kevin. I'm going to show you a picture, Jenna, because we were just having a great time
in this scene. And there were all these moments when you didn't know if you were on camera and sometimes,
他们既然已经失去了两名员工，事情将如何进行。但凯利和安吉拉只想了解更多关于查尔斯的事。我喜欢凯利问“你住在斯克兰顿哪里？”他回答“酒店”。然后安吉拉问“你出生在哪里？你出生在哪里？”太有趣了。很难不笑。我想让你们知道，当安迪在背景里问公司运营情况时，我抓到了布莱恩出戏了。那一刻他显然只是布莱恩。如果你看3分02秒，非常微妙，但看看他的脸。那是布莱恩，不是凯文。我要给你看一张照片，珍娜，因为我们在那场戏里玩得很开心。而且有很多时候你不知道自己是否在镜头里，有时，
look at that face. Oh, that's Brian. I know. That's. That's.
That's 100% Brian. He's just trying not to laugh and he's looking at John.
Well, then we're going to see Phyllis, Creed, and Stanley, sort of observing Charles in his office.
Charles is on the phone. They're like, does he eat? Does he go to the bathroom? He's a total mystery to them.
Jenna, there was more to this. There was a series of talking heads where everyone in the office is sort of commenting on how Charles is a mystery.
It starts with Angela Martin. Get ready for some titillated Angela.
Charles is a mystery.
I wish there was a way I could curl up by the fire with him and flip right to his last page.
看看那张脸。哦，那是布莱恩。我知道。那是……那是100%的布莱恩。他只是在努力不笑，他在看着约翰。好吧，然后我们将看到菲利斯、克里德和斯坦利在观察办公室里的查尔斯。查尔斯在打电话。他们心想，他吃东西吗？他去洗手间吗？对他来说，他完全是个谜。珍娜，这部分还有更多内容。有一系列采访片段，办公室里的每个人都在评论查尔斯是个谜。从安吉拉·马丁开始。准备好迎接一些心动的安吉拉吧。查尔斯是个谜。我真希望有一种方法能让我蜷缩在他身边的火堆旁，直接翻到他的最后一页。
Okay.
I am in love with that phrase.
The next time I seduce my husband, I'm going to say, baby, I want to flip right to your last page.
I know, right?
I see what he says.
I love that.
I thought that was amazing.
And then Toby has one.
好吧。我爱死这句话了。下次我诱惑我丈夫时，我要说，宝贝，我想直接翻到你的最后一页。我知道，对吧？我看看他怎么说。我喜欢这个。我觉得这太棒了。然后托比也有一个。
And Toby basically is like, I don't know why everyone thinks Charles is a mystery.
if anyone would just come back and talk to me.
I can share with you.
I have a lot of information about him if anyone just wants to talk to me.
I mean, I'm sure Toby does know where he was born, I guess.
Yeah.
And then Jenna, Charles had a really big talking head.
He's super relaxed.
托比基本上是说，我不知道为什么大家都觉得查尔斯是个谜。如果有人能回来跟我谈谈。我可以分享。如果有人想跟我谈谈，我有很多关于他的信息。我的意思是，我相信托比确实知道他出生在哪里，我想。是的。然后珍娜，查尔斯有一个非常重要的采访片段。他超级放松。
This is what it said in the script.
Charles seems relaxed, his guard down, speaking casually to the camera in a way he never would to
his employees.
Oh.
And this is what was in the shooting draft.
Mysterious?
Just because I show some restraint with my.
employees when it comes to talking about my personal life doesn't mean there's some big mystery.
剧本里是这么写的。查尔斯看起来很放松，卸下了防备，以一种他绝不会对员工说话的方式随意地对着镜头说话。哦。这就是拍摄草稿里的内容。神秘？仅仅因为我在谈论个人生活时对员工表现出一些克制，并不意味着有什么大谜团。
I grew up in a suburb of D.C. Middle class family. My dad was a CPA, went to University of Maryland,
studied business, engaged once, childhood friend, didn't work out. Then he shows a picture to the
camera. I'll always love her. Then I get my hair cut on the first day of every month, so I remember.
there's always less to cut on March 1st.
I like sour foods, but I hate grapefruit.
Couldn't tell you why.
Just don't get it.
I have a parakeet named Murphy.
我在华盛顿郊区长大。中产阶级家庭。我父亲是注册会计师，上了马里兰大学，学的是商业，订过一次婚，是青梅竹马，没成。然后他对着镜头展示了一张照片。我会永远爱她。然后我每个月的第一天都会去剪头发，这样我就能记住。3月1日总是剪得少一点。我喜欢酸的食物，但我讨厌葡萄柚。说不出为什么。就是不喜欢。我有一只叫墨菲的长尾小鹦鹉。
Trying to teach it to talk.
It repeats whatever I say.
The thing I say is squawk.
Who is this person?
I know.
Oh my gosh.
Those talking heads would have filled out the rest of the story.
I wonder if that talking head exists somewhere.
试图教它说话。它重复我说的一切。我说的东西是“嘎”。这人是谁？我知道。天哪。那些采访片段本可以填补故事的其余部分。我不知道那个采访片段是否存在于某个地方。
I don't know.
Dave Rogers.
Dave Rogers does it because that.
is priceless, but the Angela and Toby one are in the deleted scenes on the DVD.
Back at Michael's condo, he is doing some ab exercises. He is. And Jenna, if you have a camera
operator on a DVD commentary, here are some things you learn. While Michael's doing his sit-ups,
the shot that's on Pam at four minutes, 45 seconds, that was Matt Sown. Oh. You were his shot.
Okay. I don't know. I just love that. We had a fan question.
我不知道。戴夫·罗杰斯。戴夫·罗杰斯做到了，因为那……是无价的，但安吉拉和托比的片段在DVD的删减片段里。回到迈克尔的公寓，他正在做腹肌练习。他确实在做。而且珍娜，如果你在DVD评论音轨里有一个摄像师，你会学到一些事情。当迈克尔做仰卧起坐时，4分45秒拍帕姆的那个镜头，那是马特·索恩拍的。哦。你是他的镜头。好吧。我不知道。我只是喜欢这一点。我们有一个粉丝提问。
from Gianna W.
When Michael is working out in his condo, is that supposed to be the core blaster from the money
episode that he's using?
Remember he spent his money on a core blaster?
I think so.
I went to the script.
It doesn't say specifically, but I was so charmed by the scene description in the script.
Oh, let's hear it.
来自吉安娜·W。当迈克尔在他的公寓里锻炼时，那是他用的《金钱》那一集里的核心爆破器吗？记得他把钱花在核心爆破器上了吗？我想是。我查了剧本。上面没有具体说明，但我被剧本里的场景描述迷住了。哦，让我们听听。
Here's what it said.
Michael is working out on his ab roller incorrectly using no range of motion.
That is what they wanted Steve to do.
Pam can see that Michael is a little bit spiraling.
Is that a good description?
Yeah.
And she says that when she feels overwhelmed, she likes to make a list of things to do and then start with the easy stuff.
I think this is great life advice.
上面是这样写的。迈克尔正在错误地使用腹肌轮锻炼，没有任何运动幅度。这就是他们想让史蒂夫做的。帕姆能看出迈克尔有点失控了。这是一个好的描述吗？是的。她说当她感到不知所措时，她喜欢列一个待办事项清单，然后从简单的事情开始做起。我认为这是很棒的生活建议。
We got mail about that advice.
Oh, no.
And I was really flattered because.
People say, this reminds me of Jenna Fisher.
Yeah.
Because I did too.
When I rewatch this, I was like, it's a little bit of whatever.
Is it again, life imitating art?
我们收到了关于那个建议的邮件。哦，不。我真的很受宠若惊，因为……人们说，这让我想起了珍娜·费舍尔。是的。因为我也这样做。当我重看这一集时，我想，这有点……这是生活模仿艺术吗？
Do I get it right?
I got it right.
You did.
Shannon L. said, Jenna, I know that I don't know you.
But when Pam tells Michael he needs to make a list for his day, that sounded like something
you would do.
And Kayla C agrees.
She said, after listening to every episode of this podcast, I can say with confidence, that is
我做对了吗？我做对了。你做到了。香农·L说，珍娜，我知道我不认识你。但当帕姆告诉迈克尔他需要为他的一天列个清单时，那听起来像是你会做的事。凯拉·C也同意。她说，在听了这播客的每一集后，我可以自信地说，那是
the most Jenna thing I've ever heard.
I would have to say there are two things on the office that were one.
100% me. One is this list making advice and the other is my line and dinner party when I say I just
want to eat. Yeah. Those are me. You do have a chore list. You also have sort of like your meals
planned for the week. I never wonder about that. I have a plan. I like to know what I'm eating
and I like to check something off a list. You really do. I really do. When we went on our writer's
retreat, I learned very quickly that you need to know what you're eating.
Like that is no joke. I would be like, what should we do for dinner? You'd be like, I already brought stuff that we're doing this this night. And I'm like, oh, okay. We had two hello fresh nights and a takeout night. And then I said we bring our own breakfast and lunch and snacks. Done. Done. This was one of the first emails you sent to me when we were going to go on our writer's retreat. It wasn't about our work. No, no, no. It was about the meals. Let's plan our food. And then we'll come up with a work plan. I mean, I can't work on an empty stomach. No. I cannot. Well, one of the first things on Pam's list is let's just start sponsoring.
我听过的最“珍娜”的事情。我不得不说，办公室里有两件事是100%的我。一个是这个列清单的建议，另一个是我在《晚宴》里说“我只是想吃东西”的那句台词。是的。那些就是我。你确实有一个杂务清单。你也有那种为一周计划好的餐点。我从来没怀疑过这一点。我有一个计划。我喜欢知道我在吃什么，我喜欢在清单上勾掉一些东西。你确实如此。我真的如此。当我们去参加作家静修会时，我很快就了解到你需要知道你在吃什么。那可不是开玩笑的。我会说，晚餐我们该怎么办？你会说，我已经带了东西，我们这晚吃这个。我说，哦，好吧。我们有两个Hello Fresh之夜和一个外卖之夜。然后我说我们自带早餐、午餐和零食。搞定。搞定。这是你要去参加作家静修会时发给我的第一封邮件之一。不是关于我们的工作。不，不，不。是关于餐点的。让我们计划我们的食物。然后我们会想出一个工作计划。我的意思是，我不能空着肚子工作。不。我不能。好吧，帕姆清单上的第一件事就是让我们开始赞助。
all, let's get you dressed, Michael.
Yeah.
And then there's that moment where he sits in the chair across from her, and his robe opens up.
Go to Season 5 bloopers on YouTube.
Jenna, I don't even know how you salvaged anything from that scene.
Matt Sone even talked about it in the DVD commentary.
He was like, Jenna kept breaking up.
She laughed every time.
好吧，让我们帮你穿好衣服，迈克尔。是的。然后有那一刻，他坐在她对面的椅子上，他的浴袍敞开了。去YouTube上看第五季的NG片段。珍娜，我甚至不知道你是怎么从那个场景中挽救任何东西的。马特·索恩甚至在DVD评论音轨里谈到了它。他说，珍娜一直在笑场。她每次都笑。
So Steve was wearing underwear.
He was.
He was not nude.
They were like flesh toned, right?
Yes, exactly.
But on the day, we had this idea that Pam would keep talking to him, but she would just move her little clipboard up so that she wouldn't have to see him.
His business?
Yes.
所以史蒂夫穿着内衣。他穿着。他没有裸体。他们是那种肉色的，对吧？是的，完全正确。但在那一天，我们有个想法，帕姆会继续跟他说话，但她会把她的小剪贴板移上去，这样她就不必看到他。他的“生意”？是的。
But every time I did the gesture to move my clipboard up, it would make me laugh.
Like the idea of it, all of it, it was one of those moments where I couldn't stay focused because I could see it from the outside.
And it was just so tickled me.
It was such a funny moment.
And Steve never broke.
Steve could just keep a straight face.
And then I would get to a point where I couldn't go on and they'd be like, okay, cut.
But Steve would just be like, what?
但每次我做把剪贴板移上去的动作时，它都会让我笑。就像那个想法，所有的一切，这是那种我无法保持专注的时刻之一，因为我能从外面看到它。这真的让我觉得很好笑。那是一个非常有趣的时刻。史蒂夫从来没笑场。史蒂夫总是能保持严肃的表情。然后我会到一个我无法继续下去的地步，他们会说，好吧，卡。但史蒂夫只会说，什么？
Well, what is it?
I was going to play the blooper, but when I rewatched it, Jenna, you're laughing so hard, you're making no sound.
I know.
So if I played it, it just be like, ha ha ha, ha, ha.
Yes, it's true.
While we're in this moment, I would love to point out some stuff in the background.
Please.
There is a shelf of Dundies behind Michael during the scene.
好吧，怎么了？我本来要播放那个NG片段，但当我重看时，珍娜，你笑得太厉害了，一点声音都没有。我知道。所以如果我播放它，它只会是，哈哈哈哈，哈哈。是的，这是真的。当我们处于这一刻时，我很想指出背景里的一些东西。请。迈克尔身后有一个邓迪奖杯架。
Also, you probably noticed all of the inspirational posters all over the condo.
I did count, though, 10 Dundies.
Let me know if you guys got the same amount.
10 Dundies plus a no right turn, no left turn, and no U-turn sign during the scene.
Okay.
Well, I don't know if you noticed this.
I did not notice it at first, but luckily, Floor H wrote in to say,
there are two television sets in Michael's condo.
此外，你可能注意到了公寓里到处都是励志海报。我确实数了数，有10个邓迪奖杯。如果你们数出的数量一样，请告诉我。10个邓迪奖杯，加上一个“禁止右转”、“禁止左转”和“禁止掉头”的标志。好吧。我不知道你有没有注意到这个。我起初没注意到，但幸运的是，弗洛尔·H写信来说，迈克尔的公寓里有两台电视机。
Well, there's a big box one and then there's the little one.
Yes.
So you can really see it at 7 minutes, 29 seconds.
He has bought himself a new TV, but he has not taken down the broken plasma.
So it's like the new television is sitting on a TV stand.
It's your standard square TV.
It's much bigger, by the way, than the little mounted one on the wall.
Yes.
好吧，有一个大的箱式电视，还有一个小的。是的。所以你真的可以在7分29秒看到它。他给自己买了一台新电视，但他没有把坏掉的等离子电视拆下来。所以就像新电视放在电视柜上一样。这是你标准的方形电视。顺便说一句，它比墙上挂的小电视大得多。是的。
And it sits right under.
that broken one. But here's the thing, Michael is actually going to come up with some good ideas for
today. He says they should assemble a dream team, starting with Vikram. Yeah. He was the bestseller
at the telemarketing company. Pam's like, oh, okay. And he reveals that they're going to have a meeting
with a potential investor. But first, we need to get Michael dressed. Well, back at the office,
Andy has put on his computer sort of like a montage of soccer moments, right? Like a soccer photo
slideshow.
Exactly.
它就坐在那个坏掉的电视下面。但问题是，迈克尔今天确实要提出一些好主意。他说他们应该组建一个梦之队，从维克拉姆开始。是的。他是电话营销公司的销售冠军。帕姆说，哦，好吧。他透露他们要和一个潜在投资者开会。但首先，我们需要让迈克尔穿好衣服。好吧，回到办公室，安迪在他的电脑上放了一个足球时刻的蒙太奇，对吧？就像一个足球照片幻灯片。正是。
Charles sees it.
He loves soccer.
Andy is clearly sucking up to Charles.
I actually remember us talking about soccer and Idris plays soccer.
Really?
Yes.
He's like a good soccer player.
He like played growing up.
查尔斯看到了。他喜欢足球。安迪显然在拍查尔斯的马屁。我实际上记得我们谈论过足球，伊德里斯会踢足球。真的吗？是的。他是个很好的足球运动员。他从小就踢。
He like played on like a soccer league on the weekend.
So he actually knew a lot about soccer.
Well, he's British.
Football.
Yes.
What am I saying?
Football.
他周末会在足球联赛里踢球。所以他实际上对足球了解很多。好吧，他是英国人。足球。足球。是的。我在说什么？足球。
Jim has this talking head about how he's just never been a kiss up, you know?
That's just not how he operates.
And BJ talked a little bit about his own experience for this Jim Andy suck-up storyline.
Let's hear it.
This was based on my mind on an experience when I felt I had too much integrity to kiss up in a situation where I really wanted to impress people.
And I saw everyone else kissing up and getting ahead.
Man, I should just go up there, you know.
So I like the idea of a guy who does it, who just says, screw it.
吉姆有一个采访片段，讲他从来不是一个拍马屁的人，你知道吗？那不是他的行事风格。BJ谈到了他自己在这个吉姆-安迪拍马屁故事线中的经历。让我们听听。这是基于我自己的经历，当时我觉得自己太有原则了，在我想给别人留下深刻印象的情况下，我无法拍马屁。我看到其他人都在拍马屁并获得晋升。伙计，我应该直接上去，你知道。所以我喜欢一个这样做的人的想法，他只是说，去他的。
Like, I'm going to do this because this is how you get it.
head and maybe I'm being lazy by not kissing up. And then it comes back to bite him. But I liked a good guy like
Jim deciding to do it. Hmm. Interesting. Right. I just love that BJ takes moments like that and then
puts it into his episodes. No, he reflects on things in the moment and they stay with him. He's a very
thoughtful person in that way. Yeah. Well, Jim is going to suck up by pretending like he played soccer or is a
soccer player. I know. There's this moment where he's like, I'm not going to do it. I'm not going to do it. And then he just
succumbs and was like, yeah, I'm a player. And Dwight could not be happier. He's like, oh, really, Jim. I have
never heard you talk about soccer. And he's like, you should play Charles, the two of you, today. And Charles is all
就像，我要这样做，因为这就是你获得晋升的方式，也许我不拍马屁是因为我懒。然后这反过来咬了他一口。但我喜欢像吉姆这样的好人决定这样做。嗯。有趣。对。我只是喜欢BJ抓住这样的时刻，然后把它放进他的剧集里。不，他反思当下的事情，它们会留在他心里。他是一个非常有思想的人。是的。好吧，吉姆要通过假装他踢足球或是一个足球运动员来拍马屁。我知道。有那一刻，他心想，我不打算这样做。我不打算这样做。然后他屈服了，说，是的，我是个球员。德怀特高兴坏了。他说，哦，真的吗，吉姆。我从来没听你谈论过足球。他说，你今天应该和查尔斯踢一场，你们两个。查尔斯对此
about it. He's like, yes, I would love it. And Charles's whole demeanor changes.
toward Jim, toward everyone in the office. He's this very sort of smiley guy all of a sudden.
Yeah. It's a big difference. Well, now Jim's going to be in a big pickle. He said he played soccer from
second to fourth grade. He was on the orange team. I love that talking head. I do too. It made me
laugh. Well, listen, I think we should take a break because in the second half of the episode, we are going to
see this dream team get assembled and we're going to see Jim have to deal with his soccer promise.
It's good stuff.
All right.
非常感兴趣。他说，是的，我很乐意。查尔斯的整个举止都变了。对吉姆，对办公室里的每个人。他突然变成了一个非常爱笑的人。是的。差别很大。好吧，现在吉姆要陷入大麻烦了。他说他从二年级到四年级踢足球。他在橙队。我喜欢那个采访片段。我也喜欢。它让我笑了。好吧，听着，我想我们应该休息一下，因为在这一集的后半部分，我们将看到这个梦之队组建起来，我们将看到吉姆不得不处理他的足球承诺。这是好东西。好的。
We are back and you guys, the dream team got Vickram.
We got him!
Vickram!
Played by the awesome Ranjit Chowdry.
He was so fun to work with.
You know, he passed away last year.
I know.
He was so funny.
我们回来了，伙计们，梦之队得到了维克拉姆。我们得到了他！维克拉姆！由出色的兰吉特·乔杜里扮演。和他一起工作太有趣了。你知道，他去年去世了。我知道。他太有趣了。
We're in the car and, you know, Michael's all excited.
They pull up to the bowling alley.
Michael's like, I have to use the bathroom.
and Vikram has this line.
It's so good where he says, confidence, it's the food of the wise man, but the liquor of the fool.
I was so struck by this when I watched this episode.
Me too.
So I googled it because I thought, is that like an old, I don't know, expression?
我们在车里，你知道，迈克尔很兴奋。他们把车开到保龄球馆。迈克尔说，我得去洗手间。维克拉姆说了这句台词。太棒了，他说，“自信，是智者的食粮，却是愚者的美酒。”当我看到这一集时，我深受触动。我也是。所以我谷歌了一下，因为我想，那是什么古老的，我不知道，表达方式？
Proverb, like a Greek philosopher?
No, it's nowhere.
There are Reddit threads dedicated to trying to figure out where this line came from.
There was an article written about this one line.
You're kidding.
And how wise it is and how the writer of the article couldn't find its origin either.
Someone on our writing staff wrote that line.
And we don't know who?
谚语，像希腊哲学家说的？不，哪里都没有。有专门的Reddit帖子致力于弄清楚这句台词来自哪里。有一篇关于这一句台词的文章。你在开玩笑吧。它有多么明智，以及文章作者也找不到它的出处。我们编剧组的某个人写了那句台词。我们不知道是谁？
I asked BJ.
I asked Mindy.
I asked Aaron Scher.
No one can take credit for it.
Aaron Scher said something that I really liked.
He said, I don't know.
Let's give credit to the whole writing staff.
Like some sort of collective genius came up.
我问了BJ。我问了敏迪。我问了亚伦·舒尔。没人能居功。亚伦·舒尔说了一些我真的很喜欢的话。他说，我不知道。让我们把功劳归给整个编剧组。就像某种集体天才想出了
with this line. But someone wrote that from the office. And it's so good. And then last week we talked
about Vickram having this amazing talking head. That got deleted. That got deleted. This is where it would
have lived, you guys. Right after the scene in the car where he says this amazing proverb, he would have
said, when you put your telemarketing career on the line, you're not putting much on the line.
And Ranjit was just perfection. Everything. His delivery. I just.
I couldn't get enough of him.
Well, you just so believe him.
Yeah.
这句台词。但有人在《办公室》里写了它。而且它太棒了。然后上周我们谈到了维克拉姆有这个惊人的采访片段。被删了。被删了。这就是它本该存在的地方，伙计们。就在车里他说出这个惊人谚语的场景之后，他本会说，“当你把你的电话营销生涯押上时，你并没有押上多少东西。”兰吉特简直是完美。一切。他的表达。我只是……我对他看不够。好吧，你就是那么相信他。是的。
And our guest actors were always that way.
Alison Jones had this amazing ability to find people who didn't seem like they were acting at all.
Yeah.
Well, Michael is going to go into the bowling alley.
He wants a pair of nine shoes.
Guess who's working the counter?
Ryan.
Ryan, who's not on the list.
我们的客串演员总是那样。艾莉森·琼斯有一种惊人的能力，能找到那些看起来根本不像在演戏的人。是的。好吧，迈克尔要走进保龄球馆。他想要一双9号鞋。猜猜谁在柜台工作？瑞恩。瑞恩，他不在名单上。
You know, Vickram has this great line in the car where he's like,
he's been gone a long time. Is it possible he went bowling? You know him better than I do.
And I thought, Jenna, your delivery is Pam was so great when you're like, yeah. Yeah. So Pam goes in
and sees what's happening and says, this was not on the list, Michael. And then she looks at the list,
and then she's like, when did you put this on the list? I loved that. We noticed right away that
Ryan is very tan and very blonde.
I was really curious.
When did BJ know he was going to have to do this with his hair?
你知道，维克拉姆在车里有句很棒的台词，他说，“他离开很久了。他有可能去打保龄球了吗？”你比我更了解他。我想，珍娜，你作为帕姆的表达太棒了，你说“是的”。是的。所以帕姆走进去看到发生了什么，说，“这不在名单上，迈克尔。”然后她看了看名单，然后她说，“你什么时候把它加到名单上的？”我喜欢那个。我们立刻注意到瑞恩晒得很黑，头发很金。我很好奇。BJ什么时候知道他要用头发做这个？
This is what he said on the DVD commentary.
So when I was in Germany and wasn't able to be in the show for a while,
my character ran off to Thailand.
All I knew about Ryan coming back was that he was going to be blonde.
The tan.
The tan is great, too.
The tan is very funny.
I heard of the hair's frosted tips.
这是他在DVD评论音轨里说的。所以当我在德国，有一段时间不能参加演出时，我的角色跑到了泰国。关于瑞恩回来，我所知道的只是他会变成金发。晒黑。晒黑也很棒。晒黑非常有趣。我听说头发是挑染的。
And then when we did it, Mindy, whose idea it was came and was like,
No, no, no. We're only going to go for this joke once. You have to be completely blonde.
And so we dyed it and I wore a hat in public for weeks trying to save the surprise and save my dignity.
And he goes on to say that he was also touring stand-up during this time.
So he got a spray-in brown coloring, you know, that you could, like, dot.
And so he sprayed his hair brown, and then he went on stage and it started coming off, like dripping off.
Like what happened to Rudy Giuliani.
Oh, my God.
然后当我们做的时候，敏迪，那个主意是谁出的，走过来说，不，不，不。我们这个笑话只能用一次。你必须完全变成金发。所以我们把它染了，我在公共场合戴了几个星期的帽子，试图保住惊喜并保住我的尊严。他接着说，他在这段时间也在做单口喜剧巡演。所以他买了一种棕色喷雾，你知道，你可以，像，点涂。所以他把头发喷成棕色，然后他上台，它开始脱落，像滴下来一样。就像鲁迪·朱利安尼发生的那样。天哪。
Same thing.
Yes, exactly.
So he had to wear this hat, but it was like really stressful.
He was trying to keep it a secret.
I've used that spray for when my roots are coming in.
It's genius.
I love the spray, by the way.
Yeah.
一样。是的，完全正确。所以他不得不戴这顶帽子，但这真的很紧张。他试图保密。我用过那种喷雾，当我的发根长出来的时候。这是天才。顺便说一句，我喜欢这种喷雾。是的。
It's great.
But if you get really warm, it will sweat off.
Yeah.
Beware.
Where are we?
I'll give you a little location breakdown on the bowling alley. Idle hour lanes, which is the sign-out sign, is a real bowling alley in Scranton. We matched their logo. And in Scranton, there's two. And one of them is next to Poor Richards.
Yes, I've been to that one.
I thought you had.
它很棒。但如果你真的很热，它会流汗流掉。是的。小心。我们在哪？我会给你一个关于保龄球馆的地点细分。“闲暇时光球道”，那个标志，是斯克兰顿一个真正的保龄球馆。我们匹配了他们的标志。在斯克兰顿，有两个。其中一个在“可怜的理查德”旁边。是的，我去过那个。我以为你去过。
It's part of the bar, kind of.
Like when you go into poor Richards, you think, at least I thought I was walking into a bar,
but I actually was walking into a bowling alley, and then the bar was to the right.
It's interesting.
I thought that we were at Pickwick Bowl, which does have a bar next to it, sort of similar to the real
idle hour lanes.
But no, Randy Cordray said that we shot ours in Canoga Park.
It was a bowling alley in Canoga Park.
它是酒吧的一部分，某种程度上。就像当你走进“可怜的理查德”时，你以为，至少我以为我走进了一家酒吧，但我实际上走进了一个保龄球馆，然后酒吧在右边。很有趣。我以为我们在皮克威克保龄球馆，它旁边确实有一个酒吧，有点像真正的“闲暇时光球道”。但没有，兰迪·科德雷说我们在卡诺加公园拍的。那是卡诺加公园的一个保龄球馆。
I also have a little guest star shout out to the bowling alley manager who calls Ryan a shoe bitch.
He was played by Jim Woods.
He has appeared on How I Met Your Mother, Reno 9-1-1, and was a regular on the comedy satire safety geeks, S-V-I.
Again, another person who did not seem like an actor to me.
Yeah.
Seemed like a real grouchy bowling alley manager.
Exactly.
There was some delicious Pam Sass.
我还要向保龄球馆经理大喊一声，他叫瑞恩“鞋子婊子”。他由吉姆·伍兹扮演。他曾出现在《老爸老妈浪漫史》、《雷诺911》，并且是喜剧讽刺剧《安全极客》的常客。同样，又是一个在我看来不像演员的人。是的。看起来像个真正的脾气暴躁的保龄球馆经理。正是。有一些美味的帕姆式讽刺。
Because, I mean, Pam just does not like Ryan.
When he tells her he makes 60 grand a year.
And she's like, really?
They pay you a yearly salary at the bowling alley.
Yeah.
So good.
Well, the dream team is going to arrive to meet their investor.
That's right.
因为，我的意思是，帕姆就是不喜欢瑞恩。当他告诉她他一年挣6万块时。她说，真的吗？他们在保龄球馆给你发年薪。是的。太棒了。好吧，梦之队要到达去见他们的投资者了。没错。
It's at what appears to be a nursing home.
Can I tell you there was a beat in the script where Michael describes who the investor is?
Okay.
He says her name is Barbara Kivas.
She invests in local businesses, and I've been putting together a little presentation for her.
Oh.
But that didn't make it in the episode, but I'm like, okay, who's Barbara Kivas?
I've got a location breakdown on where we shot this.
那似乎是一家疗养院。我能告诉你剧本里有一个节拍，迈克尔描述投资者是谁吗？好吧。他说她的名字叫芭芭拉·基瓦斯。她投资当地企业，我一直在为她准备一个小演示。哦。但这没能进入剧集，但我心想，好吧，芭芭拉·基瓦斯是谁？我有一个关于我们在哪里拍这个的地点细分。
Oh.
Which is interesting to me.
It was a best Western hotel that was attached to the bowling alley, and we redressed their conference room to look like a nursing home.
Randy Cordray said that our location manager, Kyle Alexander, was really awesome.
that he would do this kind of thing all the time. If we had an episode that had two locations,
he would somehow manage to find them right next to each other so that we could avoid having to do
what they call a company move. Right. We have to move all the trailers, all the people,
all the equipment. Saved so much time and money. We were able to shoot the bowling alley and the
哦。这对我来说很有趣。那是一家附属于保龄球馆的贝斯特韦斯特酒店，我们重新布置了他们的会议室，让它看起来像一家疗养院。兰迪·科德雷说我们的外景经理凯尔·亚历山大真的很棒。他总是做这种事。如果我们有一集有两个地点，他会设法把它们找在彼此旁边，这样我们就可以避免做他们所谓的“公司搬迁”。对。我们必须搬运所有的拖车，所有的人，所有的设备。节省了这么多时间和金钱。我们能够拍摄保龄球馆和
nursing home all in one day. It saved so much money. It saved so much time. And Randy was just giving a lot of
compliments to Kyle saying that Kyle was able to do this all the time and it was a huge,
huge benefit to our production.
Amazing.
And it was a benefit on a very practical level because it would save the time, which also
wouldn't run down the crew as much.
And it also made it so that the actors, we could like flow from one experience sort of
emotionally in the story and comedically right into another one.
疗养院都在一天之内。节省了这么多钱。节省了这么多时间。兰迪给了凯尔很多赞美，说凯尔总是能做到这一点，这对我们的制作是一个巨大的，巨大的好处。太棒了。而且这在非常实际的层面上是一个好处，因为它会节省时间，这也不会让剧组那么累。而且它还使得演员们，我们可以从故事中的一种情感体验和喜剧体验流畅地进入另一种。
We didn't have to stop.
It was awesome on many levels.
Kyle, we love you.
Thank you, Kyle.
I want to point out, right as the dream team is entering the retirement home at 12 minutes,
was it just me?
Did anyone else notice the two, like, retirement home employees wheeling someone in a blanket?
I don't know, like, was it a corpse under a blanket?
我们不必停下来。它在很多层面上都很棒。凯尔，我们爱你。谢谢你，凯尔。我想指出，就在梦之队进入养老院时，在12分钟，是我一个人吗？还有人注意到那两个，像，养老院员工推着毯子里的人吗？我不知道，就像，毯子下面是尸体吗？
Oh, my God, I did not notice that.
I mean, I went over and over to it, just like I couldn't stop looking at it.
I was like, who is this back there?
I'm going to show you, Jenna.
It's so brief.
But look, I don't know.
This person's like on a cut or a stretcher.
Do you see?
哦，天哪，我没注意到。我的意思是，我一遍又一遍地看，就像我无法停止看它。我心想，后面那是谁？我要给你看，珍娜。太短暂了。但看，我不知道。这个人像是在担架上。你看到了吗？
Yes.
I'll put it in stories.
My other background catch for this scene is at 12 minutes, 27 seconds.
The elderly gentleman that Michael is like snapping like, hey, hey, over here.
He is watching Mori Povich.
Yes.
And it's actually Mori Povich.
That was scripted that he was watching Mori Povic.
是的。我会把它放在故事里。我这一幕的另一个背景发现是在12分钟27秒。迈克尔像“嘿，嘿，这边”那样打响指的老绅士。他正在看莫里·波维奇。是的。而且那确实是莫里·波维奇。剧本里写着他在看莫里·波维奇。
And they were able to get the rights to it.
Yes.
And on the screen, if you zoom in, there's a woman and there's a Chiron underneath her with, like, writing.
Yeah.
This is what it said.
Tell the truth.
Is my fiancé in love with my mom?
Oh.
他们能够获得版权。是的。在屏幕上，如果你放大，有一个女人，她下面有一个字幕，像，写着字。是的。上面是这样写的。“说实话。我的未婚夫爱上我妈妈了吗？”哦。
That's what they were watching.
Okay.
Well, Michael is going to make his pitch to this investment club.
And it's a real club.
There's three people, two women, and the man who's watching Mori.
But Pam and Ryan realized very quickly that one of the women is Michael.
Yeah, it's not just Barbara Kivis, it's Nana.
It's Nana.
他们看的就是这个。好吧。迈克尔要向这个投资俱乐部推销。这是一个真正的俱乐部。有三个人，两个女人，还有那个看莫里的男人。但帕姆和瑞恩很快意识到其中一个女人是迈克尔的……是的，不仅仅是芭芭拉·基瓦斯，是奶奶。是奶奶。
During this pitch, he's going to start by introducing his team.
BJ said he loved that he got the title in the episode.
Oh, yeah.
It's always kind of a fun thing when that happens.
So Michael's like, ladies and gentlemen, I present to you the dream team.
Did you notice at 13 minutes, 20 seconds, when Michael is introducing Ryan, that he winks at Nana?
while eating vanilla pudding in like a flirty way. And Nana is delighted. I know. I mean, he's buttering her up in the best way.
Ryan is a hot mess. BJ said, by the way, that he ate a ton of vanilla pudding and that it was delicious.
在这次推销中，他要从介绍他的团队开始。BJ说他喜欢他在这一集里得到了标题。哦，是的。当这种情况发生时，总是很有趣。所以迈克尔说，女士们，先生们，我向你们介绍梦之队。你注意到在13分钟20秒，当迈克尔介绍瑞恩时，他向奶奶眨眼了吗？一边吃香草布丁，以一种调情的方式。奶奶很高兴。我知道。我的意思是，他正在以最好的方式讨好她。瑞恩是个烂摊子。顺便说一句，BJ说他吃了一吨香草布丁，而且很美味。
I love a vanilla pudding. I also want to point out that at 13 minutes, 41 seconds, there is a big zit on my jaw line.
No. This is the only time you see it. Because at 14 minutes,
minutes, 46 seconds, the Zit is gone. So clearly, I got a touch up in various takes.
I did not notice that. It's so large. It's one of those undergrounders. Oh, yeah. That is, you know,
had its own heartbeat. And I would get those on my jawline. But thank you, Laverne, for covering that up by 14
minutes, 46 seconds. And by the way, I can imagine, because they almost never let us get touchups after we
started rolling. I can imagine Levern sitting at the monitors and just being like, you need to
let me get in there. You need to let me get in there. And so she probably convinced them and she was
我喜欢香草布丁。我还想指出，在13分钟41秒，我的下巴线上有一个大痘痘。不。这是你唯一一次看到它。因为在14分钟46秒，痘痘不见了。所以很明显，我在不同的镜头里得到了修补。我没注意到。它太大了。它是那种地下的。哦，是的。那是，你知道，有自己的心跳。我会在我的下巴线上长那些。但谢谢你，拉弗恩，在14分钟46秒前把它遮住了。顺便说一句，我可以想象，因为他们几乎从不让我们在开始拍摄后进行修补。我可以想象拉弗恩坐在监视器前，就像，“你需要让我进去。你需要让我进去。”所以她可能说服了他们，她
able to come in and touch up my Zit. But you do see it 13 minutes, 41 seconds. Do you know what was
super embarrassing and this would happen every once in a while? What? Is when like someone like Matt
sewn camera operator would be like you would hear him sort of radio, hey, um, LeVern, what?
Why don't she step in?
Yeah.
It's because he is looking at it through the camera.
That's true.
That happened to me.
能够进来修补我的痘痘。但你确实在13分钟41秒看到了它。你知道什么是超级尴尬的，这偶尔会发生吗？什么？就是当像马特·索恩这样的摄像师会像，你会听到他通过无线电说，“嘿，嗯，拉弗恩，什么？为什么她不进去？”是的。因为他通过摄像机看着它。这是真的。那发生在我身上。
That happened to me one time I definitely had like one big one on my forehead.
And Matt was like, I think we should get a little powder for you.
I'm like, oh my God, Matt!
Well, have you know, the woman in this investment group who wants to give Michael the money was played by Eve Seagall.
Eve has appeared in Shameless Superstar, Dead to Me, and Legion.
I was not able to figure out who played the gentleman.
It was a non-speaking role.
So he was a background performer.
那发生在我身上一次，我额头上肯定有一个大的。马特说，“我想我们应该为你涂点粉。”我心想，哦，天哪，马特！好吧，你知道，这个投资小组里想给迈克尔钱的女人是由伊芙·西格尔扮演的。伊芙曾出现在《无耻之徒》、《超级明星》、《死于我手》和《军团》。我没能找出是谁扮演了那位绅士。那是一个非说话角色。所以他是一个背景表演者。
So he is uncredited as far as I can find.
But, you know, in the end, Nana is going to say no.
Nana says, this is an investment club.
We're not about handouts here.
And so she's a no.
In the car ride leaving there, Vickram made me laugh because he's like,
Nana brought up some good points.
I know.
所以据我所知，他没有署名。但是，你知道，最后，奶奶要说不。奶奶说，“这是一个投资俱乐部。我们这里不是为了施舍。”所以她拒绝了。在离开那里的车程中，维克拉姆让我笑了，因为他说，“奶奶提出了几点很好的意见。”我知道。
And then he's like, what kind of name is Nana?
And Pam's like, it means grandmother.
And then Vickram is like, I'm out.
He's like, sweet Jesus.
At Dundra Mifflin, the soccer game is about to be underway.
There was a deleted Dwight talking head.
He is setting up the whole parking lot.
He's drawing chalk.
然后他说，Nana是什么名字？Pam说，意思是祖母。然后Vickram说，我不干了。他说，天哪。在邓德米福林，足球比赛即将开始。有一个被删减的Dwight的采访片段。他正在布置整个停车场。他在用粉笔画线。
I wondered how it got there.
Yeah, the cones.
There's a talking head while Dwight's doing this.
And he shares one of his childhood dreams.
Can we hear that?
When I was a child, I always dreamed of being a referee, penalizing people.
enforcing the rules, but I never could have dreamed of this.
Wow.
我很好奇它是怎么在那里的。对，那些锥筒。Dwight做这些的时候有一个采访片段。他分享了他童年的一个梦想。我们能听听吗？当我还是个孩子的时候，我一直梦想成为一名裁判，惩罚别人，执行规则，但我从未梦想过会是这样。哇。
He would have been a great referee, actually.
Yeah.
Very quickly, we see that the group of Dundermifflin employees,
they don't know anything about soccer.
In the deleted scenes, there was a moment where Creed picks up the soccer ball
and throws it at Kelly's back like dodgeball.
And he's like, you're out.
Oh.
他其实会是个很棒的裁判。是的。很快，我们看到邓德米福林的员工们对足球一窍不通。在删减片段中，有一个Creed捡起足球像玩躲避球一样扔向Kelly背后的镜头。他说，你出局了。哦。
Well, this is interesting because we got a piece of mail from Kyle T.
who wanted to know how long did you guys have to play soccer?
Did you have any training or did they just let you guys go crazy?
Was any of it choreographed?
You were there.
I mean, obviously the stunt that's coming up was choreographed.
But the other stuff, was it just kind of free form?
Yeah, we could just sort of like fart around in the background.
嗯，这很有趣，因为我们收到了一封来自Kyle T.的邮件，他想知道你们踢了多久的足球？你们接受过训练吗，还是他们就让你们随便踢？有编排吗？你在现场。我的意思是，即将到来的那个特技显然是编排好的。但其他部分，是自由发挥吗？是的，我们可以在背景里随便乱踢。
Okay.
I did ask for sneakers, so I'm in sneakers.
I thought Angela Martin might have taken it very seriously.
Sure.
So I'm in my sneakers.
And then I actually caught a moment in the background that,
that I kind of vaguely remember because it was that art imitating life, life imitating art, whatever.
Phyllis actually did get hit with the ball.
好的。我确实要求穿运动鞋，所以我穿了运动鞋。我以为Angela Martin可能会非常认真地对待这件事。当然。所以我穿着运动鞋。然后我确实在背景里捕捉到了一个瞬间，我隐约记得，因为那是艺术模仿生活，生活模仿艺术，诸如此类。Phyllis确实被球击中了。
What?
When we were just horsing around.
And you can see it?
It's very subtle in the background.
Hit where?
I think up in her upper torso.
Not hard, right?
But that we were kicking around back there.
什么？当我们只是在胡闹的时候。你能看到吗？在背景里非常不明显。击中哪里？我想是她的上半身。不重，对吧？但那是我们在后面踢球的时候。
If you go to 19 minutes, 28 seconds, tell me what you see.
It was Creed.
Creed, which is no surprise.
to me because Creed would sometimes get a little crazy with props. So I did a slow motion screen
play by play. Okay. That I will put in our stories. If my memory is correct, it didn't hurt,
but she did get hit with the soccer ball. And we were like, oh my gosh. Okay. So here's the
beginning of the ball. Okay. Okay. Okay. Wow. It's high up. Yep. Next frame. See where it's
headed. Right to her face. I know, Phyllis in the red sweater. Ironically. Then you kind of see her
如果你去到19分28秒，告诉我你看到了什么。是Creed。Creed，这对我来说并不奇怪，因为Creed有时会用道具搞得有点疯狂。所以我做了一个慢动作逐帧回放。好的。我会把它放在我们的故事里。如果我的记忆没错，那并不疼，但她确实被足球击中了。我们当时想，天哪。好的。这是球的开始。好的。好的。好的。哇。很高。是的。下一帧。看它要去哪。直奔她的脸。我知道，穿红毛衣的Phyllis。讽刺的是。然后你看到她
bending over. And then here... I see what looks like some people running to her aide. Yeah, Ed. You see the
ball sort of hitting right there in her red. It looks like her shoulder maybe. There it makes contact. And then
here you kind of see her face. Yeah. Like she's kind of bending to the side. So yeah. Oh my gosh,
Phyllis did get hit with the ball in the episode where she gets hit with the ball. Yes. And so did Kelly.
A lot of people getting hit with the ball. Well, we did also get
some fan mail people wanted to know, did Phyllis perform her own stunt? Now, this is totally separate,
guys. You know, what I just showed you was not the scripted moment. Here's what happens. There's this
moment where Charles is going to kick the ball super hard toward Jim and Jim ducks and Phyllis gets
弯下腰。然后这里……我看到看起来像是有几个人跑去帮她。是的，Ed。你看到球大概就在那里击中了她的红色衣服。看起来可能是她的肩膀。那里发生了接触。然后在这里你看到她的脸。是的。就像她正向一侧弯曲。所以是的。天哪，Phyllis确实在那个她被球击中的剧集里被球击中了。是的。Kelly也是。很多人被球击中了。好吧，我们确实也收到了一些粉丝邮件，人们想知道，Phyllis是自己完成的特技吗？现在，这完全是另一回事了，伙计们。你知道，我刚才给你们看的那不是剧本里的时刻。事情是这样的。有一个时刻，Charles要用力把球踢向Jim，Jim躲开了，Phyllis被
clocked in the face. And everybody is like, Jim, why did you duck? Yeah, Dwight's like,
Jim, why did you duck? An experienced soccer player wouldn't duck. First of all, I will tell you,
you that there was no soccer ball used in this particular shot. Idris was kicking air and Phyllis
faked getting hit. It is an amazing faky hit. Yes. Randy Cordray told me that we added the
soccer ball using CGI magic. It was the folks at Stargate International. Randy actually said,
I dare say, it's one of the most effective uses of CGI that the office ever incorporated. I mean, it looks
totally real. Big applause to John for his like faky seeing of the ball and ducking. I mean, all of it. It all
works. And then Phyllis is like, I think I swallowed a crown. I know. We also got a fan mail flurry.
击中了脸。每个人都说，Jim，你为什么要躲？是的，Dwight说，Jim，你为什么要躲？有经验的足球运动员是不会躲的。首先，我要告诉你们，在这个特定的镜头里没有使用足球。Idris踢的是空气，Phyllis假装被击中。这是一个惊人的假动作。是的。Randy Cordray告诉我，我们使用CGI魔法添加了足球。是Stargate International的人做的。Randy实际上说，我敢说，这是《办公室》有史以来最有效的CGI应用之一。我的意思是，它看起来完全真实。为John那种假装看到球并躲避的演技鼓掌。我的意思是，这一切都很有效。然后Phyllis说，我想我吞下了一个牙冠。我知道。我们还收到了一阵粉丝邮件。
What about? Jim ducking. Oh, is this a soccer fan mail flurry? Like soccer. Yeah.
People coming to Jim's defense. Oh. So Ashley T. said, I don't understand. I don't understand.
understand how Jim got blamed for this soccer ball hitting Phyllis in the face.
Charles is the one who kicked it. It's clearly Charles's fault because I would have ducked too.
Joseph F. said, listen, I get it that maybe an experienced soccer player shouldn't have ducked,
that they should have jumped up and intercepted the ball with their chest. However, Charles crossed
the ball toward the side, in which case Jim and any other professional player would have ducked.
Really? Because what? Then the ball goes out? I guess so. Oh. Yeah. Mm-hmm. How about that? So a fan mail flurry, lots of people commenting that Jim was not wrong for ducking. I do not know enough about soccer to comment. I don't either, even though I live on a soccer field every single Saturday with our kids. Like we're always there. And my husband played soccer and he's coaching soccer. I should have asked Josh about it.
关于什么？Jim躲避。哦，这是一阵关于足球的粉丝邮件吗？像足球。是的。人们站出来为Jim辩护。哦。所以Ashley T.说，我不明白。我不明白Jim怎么会因为这个足球击中Phyllis的脸而被责怪。是Charles踢的。这显然是Charles的错，因为我也会躲。Joseph F.说，听着，我明白也许有经验的足球运动员不应该躲，他们应该跳起来用胸部拦截球。然而，Charles把球传向了侧面，在这种情况下，Jim和任何其他职业球员都会躲开。真的吗？因为什么？然后球出界了？我想是吧。哦。是的。嗯。怎么样？所以是一阵粉丝邮件，很多人评论说Jim躲避并没有错。我对足球了解不够，无法评论。我也不了解，尽管我每个星期六都和我们的孩子待在足球场上。就像我们总是在那里。而且我丈夫踢足球，他还在教足球。我应该问问Josh。
Lee is coaching both of our kids' soccer teams this year.
I know.
Both of our husbands are soccer coaches this year.
Yeah.
And I just sit there and I'm just trying to figure out off sides.
I'll never figure it out.
I don't get it.
Lee今年在教我们两个孩子的足球队。我知道。我们两个丈夫今年都是足球教练。是的。而我只是坐在那里，试图弄明白越位。我永远也弄不明白。我不懂。我永远也弄不明白。
I don't think the kids get it.
No.
The referees call it.
I don't get it.
I'm like, what happened off sides?
What?
Listen, I've said in this episode that I don't know much about basketball.
That's true.
我不认为孩子们懂。不。裁判判罚它。我不懂。我就像，越位发生了什么？什么？听着，我在这一集里说过，我对篮球了解不多。那是真的。
I don't know a lot about soccer.
But talk to me about hockey.
football or baseball. You're very well-versed in hockey. I don't get hockey. I'm like into those sports. A live
hockey game, there's nothing like it. I think it's the best sport to watch live. Personally, I know people
love watching basketball live. I mean, watching basketball live, especially if you can get close to the
court, it's like an amazing game live. I just love the whole hockey community. I love everything about it.
I went one time and met some of your hockey mom friends. Yeah. And what I didn't know you guys is that
hockey games. They served beer at 10 in the morning. They do. I was like, oh my gosh. They sure do.
我对足球了解不多。但跟我谈谈曲棍球、橄榄球或棒球吧。你对曲棍球非常精通。我不懂曲棍球。我喜欢那些运动。现场曲棍球比赛，没有什么比得上它。我认为这是现场观看最好的运动。就我个人而言，我知道人们喜欢现场看篮球。我的意思是，现场看篮球，特别是如果你能靠近球场，那是一场很棒的现场比赛。我只是喜欢整个曲棍球社区。我喜欢关于它的一切。我有一次去看了，还见了一些你的曲棍球妈妈朋友。是的。我不知道的是，伙计们，曲棍球比赛。他们在早上10点供应啤酒。他们确实供应。我当时想，天哪。他们确实供应。
We have like juice boxes at soccer. They have beer. I remember going to like one of our early
hockey games for my son and it was at 7.30 in the morning and I brought a coffee and people were like,
does anyone want a beer from the concessions? I was like, um, okay. I don't think so, but thank you.
Pretty amazing. Well, listen.
The Dream Team has lost a member and they get back to Michael's condo.
Ryan's going to run inside.
He wants to watch The Closer on TNT.
Very important to him.
我们在足球比赛时有果汁盒。他们有啤酒。我记得去参加我儿子的一场早期曲棍球比赛，那是早上7点半，我带了一杯咖啡，人们问，有人想从特许摊位买啤酒吗？我当时想，嗯，好吧。我想不用了，但谢谢。太神奇了。好吧，听着。梦之队失去了一名成员，他们回到了Michael的公寓。Ryan要跑进去。他想看TNT台的《罪案终结》。对他来说非常重要。
Pam's upset.
She can't get out of the car.
Now Pam's going to spiral.
So guess what?
It was not in the script that you stayed in the car.
I remember.
It was Jen Salada's idea.
And she fought for it to have Pam stay in the car during the scene.
Pam很心烦。她下不了车。现在Pam要崩溃了。所以猜猜怎么着？你待在车里并不是剧本里的。我记得。那是Jen Salada的主意。她争取让Pam在这一幕中待在车里。
Yeah, I was supposed to get out of the car and then sort of the
idea was lean against it. And part of that was because it would be really easy to stage it camera
wise. Yeah. Well, I loved her staying in the car. And I love this shot at 16 minutes, 22 seconds when you
see Pam in the side mirror and Michael standing next to the car. It's such a cool shot.
I had to bring a lot of emotion to the scene. You had to see Pam be convinced by Michael.
And this is one of those moments when Michael becomes really good at
being a boss. And he's so serious. He's like, listen, kiddo. Yeah. You quit. I quit. So that's the truth.
It was very easy to get emotional because to have Steve Correll say, listen, kiddo. I mean, I know he wasn't much older than us, but he did always have sort of like a wise fatherly. He was our mentor. Yeah. Like, exactly. And so to have your mentor coach you, it felt real. It felt real.
是的，我本应该下车，然后想法是靠在车上。部分原因是这样在摄像机角度上很容易布置。是的。嗯，我很喜欢她待在车里。我喜欢16分22秒的那个镜头，当你看到侧视镜里的Pam和站在车旁的Michael。那是一个很酷的镜头。我必须为这一幕带来很多情感。你必须看到Pam被Michael说服。这是Michael变得非常擅长当老板的时刻之一。他非常严肃。他说，听着，孩子。是的。你辞职。我也辞职。所以这就是真相。要变得情绪化很容易，因为Steve Carell说，听着，孩子。我的意思是，我知道他并不比我们大多少，但他确实总是有一种睿智的父亲般的感觉。他是我们的导师。是的。就像，完全正确。所以让你的导师指导你，感觉很真实。感觉很真实。
You know, and it made me emotional.
And we just really connected there in a real way.
And it was really sweet.
I just love those Pam Michael moments that reminds me of when he came to her art show.
And he shows up for her.
Yeah.
And it was great.
Well, next we're going to see Michael on the phone.
你知道，这让我很感动。我们在那里以一种真实的方式真正建立了联系。这真的很甜蜜。我只是喜欢那些Pam和Michael的时刻，这让我想起他去参加她的艺术展的时候。他为她出现。是的。这太棒了。好吧，接下来我们要看到Michael在打电话。
And he's asking Billy Merchant if he has any free office space anywhere.
Because they can't work out of Michael's condo anymore.
They're going to throw them out.
They got a letter.
and Billy says, I got something for you.
It's like a supply room maybe, but there's also like a shower?
It's also back at the Dunder-Mifflin-Skranton building.
Yeah, I probably should have led with that.
他在问Billy Merchant是否有任何空闲的办公空间。因为他们不能再在Michael的公寓里工作了。他们要被赶出去了。他们收到了一封信。Billy说，我有一些东西给你。可能是一个储藏室，但也有一个淋浴间？它也在邓德米福林斯克兰顿大楼里。是的，我可能应该先说这个。
And that's exactly right.
It's like a supply room closet, but the gang is like, I could work here.
Yeah, they can see it.
And it's really sweet because the episode ends with Michael adding Michael Scott
paper company to the little board in the lobby, and Pam's handing him the little letters.
Matt Sone shared that there was a take where instead of you guys already having the letters,
that you were taking the letters from other people's businesses' names.
Oh, yeah, I remember that.
完全正确。那就像一个储藏室壁橱，但大家说，我可以在这里工作。是的，他们能看到。这真的很甜蜜，因为这一集以Michael把“Michael Scott纸业公司”加到大厅的小板子上结束，Pam递给他那些小字母。Matt Sone分享说，有一个拍摄版本，你们不是已经有了字母，而是从别人的公司名字上取下字母。哦，是的，我记得那个。
I remember that.
Which is really funny to me.
And there was a tag that didn't make it in the episode.
Kevin is back at reception.
The phone rings.
Kevin answers it.
and he's able to transfer the call to Dwight successfully.
He's so happy.
我记得那个。这对我来说真的很有趣。还有一个没有进入剧集的标签。Kevin回到了接待处。电话响了。Kevin接了电话。他成功地把电话转接给了Dwight。他太高兴了。
He looks all cocky to camera.
Charles comes out and says,
Hey, Kevin, I need you to set up a conference call with David Wallace and the other branch managers in 10 minutes.
I'll take it in the conference room.
Kevin looks like he's going to crap his pants.
He goes, you got it, boss.
And then he runs out of the office and never comes back.
You know, I asked Brian, what was it like to be at the reception?
他看起来对镜头很自负。Charles走出来说，嘿，Kevin，我需要你在10分钟内安排一个与David Wallace和其他分公司经理的电话会议。我会在会议室接听。Kevin看起来快要吓尿了。他说，没问题，老板。然后他跑出办公室，再也没有回来。你知道，我问Brian，在那一周坐在接待处是什么感觉？你知道，因为我注意到在整集中，他都在背景里。他做着我必须做的事情，那就是在背景里待很长时间。他确实指出，仅仅因为你们在角落里，这是你们谈论过的事情，你知道，他们会让你们站在复印机旁。所以他很高兴他能坐着完成他的背景工作。我告诉你，我站了将近九年。是的。
desk for that week.
You know, because I noticed throughout the whole episode, he's in the background.
And he was doing what I had to do, which is be in the background a lot.
And he did point out that just because you guys were in the corner, which is something you've
talked about, you know, they would make you guys stand at the copier.
So he was just happy he got to sit for his background work.
I'm telling you, I stood for almost nine years.
Yeah.
我喜欢那个。好吧，那是梦之队。接下来是Michael Scott纸业公司。我们要在那间小储藏室里忙碌起来了。我等不及了。我也是。好的。祝你们这周过得愉快。
I love that.
Well, that was Dream Team.
Next up is Michael Scott Paper Company.
We're going to get busy in that little storage room.
I can't wait.
Me too.
All right.
Have a great week, you guys.
到时候见。感谢收听Office Ladies的第二杯。这一集最初是与Earwolf合作创作的。Office Ladies是Odyssey的节目，由Jenna Fisher和Angela Kinsey制作。我们的高级制片人是Matt Beagle。我们的第二杯剧集由Molly Nugent制作。音频工程师是Sam Pfeiffer。Odyssey的执行制片人是Leah Reese Dennis。
See you then.
Thank you for listening to Office Ladies' Second Drink.
This episode was initially created in collaboration with Earwolf.
Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey.
Our senior producer is Matt Beagle.
Our Second Drinks episodes are produced by Molly Nugent.
Audio engineer is Sam Pfeiffer.
Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis.
Office Ladies由Bill Schultz混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是Creed Bratton的Rubber Tree。
Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Schultz.
Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton.
Office Ladies由Bill Schultz混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是Creed Bratton的Rubber Tree。